it has been 43 days
and president joe biden has not given a
press conference and i guess there's a
video going around where
it was posted earlier today joe biden is
doing some kind of
tele press conference and he says okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna take your questions
now if that's what i'm supposed
to do and then all of a sudden the
camera turns off
and then all of a sudden the screen goes
to an image that says thanks for joining
and that was it no questions allowed and
as we were talking about this wondering
is this the is this really the biggest
news i mean just joe biden calling a lid
like he normally does
we noticed something we got jack murphy
hanging out what's up everybody good to
be here it's every other wednesday night
but he was like where's the state of the
union address and i was like well
it's it's it's an inaugural year it's
his first year i mean maybe they don't
give one right so
we went back all the way to 1977.
that's how long that's the uh the amount
of time
where this is unprecedented so i don't i
don't want to say unprecedented almost
unprecedented because in 1977
jimmy carter waited until like april
18th
to give a a a speech to the joint
session of congress
we are now on march 3rd and not only has
joe biden not given a press conference
not only are they turning off his camera
so he can't answer questions
he's not given a state of union address
and every president up until 1977 by
this time had already done it jimmy
carter was the outlier
again not unprecedented but just really
creepy combined with everything now look
jimmy carter giving the state of the
union i think in april
made sense simply because it was gerald
ford before uh gerald ford
before him only like three days before
he was inaugurated where he gave an
address like
right up until the last minute so it
seemed like carter was like i should
probably wait a little bit maybe because
it's just
too many addresses going to the nation
this joe biden stuff is
is pretty creepy and now we got there's
this claim that on march 4th
militia groups are going to storm dc or
something i tell you this joe biden not
giving a state of the union is certainly
adding fuel to the fire of these
conspiracies so we'll talk about that
we've got some other cultural stories we
got stuff about a netflix producer
claiming the cpac stage was a nazi
symbol but now we know is actually made
by a democrat so
that's a weird backfiring and then we
have uh crazy story there's a there's
a emergency announcement birth rates are
declining to such an extent
it is being called an emergency and a
crisis so we'll talk about these things
as i mentioned jack murphy's hanging out
what's up everybody good to be here nice
to see everybody sitting in a different
chair tonight
every other wednesday glad to be here
thanks for having me you're very clean
jack
thank you appreciate it i get to trim up
every other wednesday come in here nice
and smooth i never knew until just now
yeah what's up everybody ian crossland
in the house good to see you all in
crossland.net
yeah and then i am sour patch lids
pushing buttons in the corner as i do
luke rodkowski is currently on vacation
he swears he's coming back but i'm not
sure i believe him
luke because that guy's like he'll just
be like hey i'm in i'm in
cuba it's like what what are you doing
down there it's like i'm actually going
to argentina it's like
okay in the rv no less in the rv it's
like on the water
it's impressive well let's let's we're
going to go through this news before we
do head over to timcast.com and become a
member because we have a bunch of
exclusive episodes
segments and everything for those that
aren't already members
it's not just three clips look i can
keep loading more and more look we got
we got a full
hour talking about kangaroos with sydney
watson we have fun we got
we got james o'keefe for over an hour
just ragging on the media we got full
bonus episodes as well as just a ton of
bonus segments so
become a member because in the event
that we get banned
which seems possible considering we're
in this purge
this is where the content will live and
we're also building up a big network
we've got a new show coming it's on
crime cults mysteries
and the paranormal that's going to be
cassandra fairbanks and it's
it's going to be like evergreen not
super newsy but this is going to get
these crazy some of the people already
talking to about coming out and talking
about stuff
people are going to be like how could
you have that person in your house and
i'm like yeah that's probably a good
point but it's going to be awesome
so make sure uh that that is all coming
and uh sign up there but let's let's do
this
the first thing i want to show you is a
story from fox news
biden still hasn't held a press
conference after 43 days in office
the subhead for the fox news article
says quote i think his people keep him
away from the media
because they're afraid he might trail
off or have difficulty answering basic
questions
which brings me to this video clip from
the first
check this out i'm going to play this
for you and i'm happy to take questions
if that's you
i'm supposed to do nance whatever you
want me to do
and just for those listening the fee
just cuts out and then it says thank you
for joining
so it wasn't an accident there's no way
it's as president biden participates in
a virtual event with the house
democratic caucus
it just turns off that's it so again not
only has biden not called a press
conference
like apparently his handlers aren't
allowing him to do it and i don't mean
handle like some grand conspiracy where
he's the manchurian candidate or
something
i mean literally like the people working
with him are like come on biden it's
time to go to bed they put him in the
wheelchair with a blanket on his lap and
he goes and they card him away
and uh this is what we saw today so it
was this clip jack
dex like you see this clip check this
out and then you i think you asked about
the state of the union right yeah and
then we just started digging doing some
real
investigative journalism over here
trying to figure out what's really going
on you know if i got elected president
and i had been
vice president and i had been the one
sitting in the chair
up behind the president all those times
listening applauding like a seal every
time the president
said standing up when you're supposed to
if i had my chance
to finally be the guy giving the speech
with the two people behind me
cheering me on and clapping me on and
the whole nation watching and
joint session of congress state of the
union address i'm the
president of the united states i'd be
trying to schedule that thing day after
freaking
honor inauguration let me pull the dates
so we go back to 2017. the first thing
was first question we asked was okay
well it's it's his first year in office
do they give a state of the union
address like within a month
of being inaugurated donald trump
february 28 2017
okay that was his first public address
it was donald trump's speech to the
joint session of congress
all right well well trump did it so then
oh let's go back to obama
2009 obama's speech to joint attention
of congress february 24th
all right well what about george w bush
so we tried searching wikipedia sure
enough there's nothing listed
why because bush didn't call it a state
of the union
but on february 27th he held an address
to the joint session of congress
all right well let's go back even
further we have
bill clinton president's address to the
joint session
1993 state of the union february 17th
william j clinton presidential library
all right then we've got
february 9th 1989 the scene bush senior
we go back to the reagan library
february 18th 1981
and then we stop here president carter
1977
april 20th but i believe the date is
actually listed as april 18th
in in media but we have here from the
history art and archives this
is house.gov saying april 20th 1977.
that's how far back you have to go in
order to find a time where a president
has gone this
long without giving a state of the union
or
joint a speech to the joint session of
congress so again
not unprecedented just it's been a
really long time
in my lifetime and i'm old yeah it's
been in my lifetime and i'm old and it
didn't happen it hasn't happened why not
wouldn't you be excited to do it yeah
it's a different generation it's a
different time he should be giving
youtube
making youtube videos if not daily
weekly well yes that's of course a
social media strategy is something that
they all should really be employing and
they're not and trump should have been
doing that and he didn't
however come on i mean he kind of did
but it was i wouldn't call it a strategy
you know what i mean well i just
i wish and and guys in our circle have
been calling for this he should have
been doing periscopes he should have
been doing
live streams he should have been letting
people in on the inside and going direct
but anyway another topic for
conversation
jimmy carter joe biden here
joe biden he i don't think has the
stamina to stand up there
does he no that's i think that's it
that's why they won't let him answer
questions you know why
when he said in that video he's like
i'll take some questions
they're going to go um president biden
and then they're going to call out
something like
cuomo huh people dead in nursing homes
and he's going to go oh
drew another shop at a brother and then
people are going to be like
it's been a while since i've heard his
voice and when you played that he
sounded
just haggard haggar who's nancy
he asked he's like i'll i'll take some
questions if that's what i'm going to do
nancy it was the house democratic
constitution
oh nancy yes if i'm supposed maybe she
was the one she was like no
got him up isn't she older than he is
she is but she does seem to be a little
bit more lucid spry yeah she's pretty
yeah
botox i don't know if that's keeping her
going
but so i think biden got an eyelid is
that what that's called yeah yeah
probably
he got a lot of work done and he's a
really old guy well imagine what you
know you saw what happened to
obama you saw what happened to bush and
dr reagan how the presidency ages people
yeah dude
it did not age trump i noticed did not
age trump at all as a matter of fact
anything that de-aged him
but biden though he may just
disintegrate did you see the
was it the onion article i think where
it was like uh presidency ages bited in
first term it was a picture of like a
corpse just totally rotted like
yeah because the image is hilarious
oh boy do we stress oh my gosh
pull it up stress of presidency already
ages by intention
and it's just a mummified biden like but
like a joint session
of congress where the president
addresses them and the nation on every
network
everybody stops everything to pay
attention that is a major moment for
america right
and what uh time right now
we're in don't you think with january 6
that
we need to heal and all this stuff
unify and get past the election don't
you think that this more than ever
should be a time for the president to
address everyone
everyone but let's be honest do you
really think joe biden getting up before
a joint state of congress
and spouting out true and on a shabbat
of pressure is going to unite people
i mean look it's funny i use i use that
word because i don't know what else
word you use to describe his inability
to speak but that one or bad a cath care
he's going to get up there and he's
going to be like my follow my fellow
mexicans mexicans americans my fellow
uh uh uh you know
the people in the country uh uh
but that's but it's state of the union
they've got the teleprompters there's no
questions we're in a national
crisis the cut the city is under siege
and occupied
there's barbed wire fences around the
capitol now to take the other
counter position perhaps this is and i
hate doing this
the other position perhaps though this
is congruent with the state of emergency
in the district of columbia the national
guard presence potential threats of
march 4th
new people storming the capital maybe
it's just too high of a security risk
but
wouldn't they say that wouldn't they
even just come out and be like too high
security rests
they're gonna postpone it dude that that
video creeps me out
the video where biden's talking and they
turn the camera off i'm like he's like
i'll do it i'll take questions
i'll take some questions can i please
can i plea
i'm just imagining like he's sitting
there and like xi jinping is
like he's like standing with his arms
crossed by the camera and then when he's
like i'll answer questions he goes
and they cut it off and it's like i'm
kidding about g
i'm just saying like when joe biden is
on camera saying i'll do the questions
and then someone turns it off
who right just turned the president of
these united states
off in an address to the democratic
congress
a caucus who did that who overrode the
president himself
that is freaking me out imagine if that
happened with trump trump i'll take some
questions and people started to turn it
off
no the joke the joke was fit you know
they turned off andrew yang's mic in the
democratic debate
did they yeah yeah yeah because you
could watch him he's talking and he's
like
i'm here to talk about universal basic
and then you see him like very faintly
from the other microphones and his mouth
was moving
trump would grab the other person's mic
and go excuse me excuse me you don't
turn my microphone off
no no listen i'm talking right right
shut them all down
right biden does not have the fight in
him you can
turn the cameras off could you imagine
the present
dude i need to stress this to all of you
listening at home my fellow americans
the president of the united states was
speaking to members of congress
and offered to answer questions and then
abruptly and without any communication
from the president
someone disconnected his communications
who
overrode the president what network was
it on
it was at whitehouse.gov wow
whitehouse.gov
turned his cam this made this is i'm
going to say right now in case i'm
getting punked
is a video fake it was posted by a bunch
of verified people
it was posted by the first on tv so it's
like a tv network
so what is this are we being are we
being punched right now and this video
is going to go viral with all these left
just being like
dummy is he thought it was real i don't
know it's congruent
which makes it believable that's a scary
thing right it's totally congruent
outside of that whole scenario the
bigger picture is no state of the union
address no press conferences
nope right it's sad the way he even it
was like i guess i'll take questions now
if that's what i'm supposed he was like
willing like what old miserable
loose he's obviously clearly not in
control no
he's not in control of the things he
says the way he spends his time
the way he can communicate to the
american people most likely
in his decision making about what
politics are doing so let's tie this
together
remember the syrian strikes a few days
ago yep
kamala harris apparently was answering
phone calls for him
but but apparently kamala harris did not
even know she was not told
she was upset that she wasn't in the
loop right
who knew who made the decision
who is controlling joe biden you know
trump changed some of the laws regarding
drone strikes and gave
control of that to the military so it
could have been people in the military
making the decision
look at this look at this story veep
kamala harris takes foreign calls on
behalf of joe biden february 16th
geez some something creepy man
and i'll say this i'll say this in the
video where joe biden is speaking
i'm willing to bet that's a green screen
behind him
that's right i'm half kidding i think it
is a green screen but it's not like a
nefarious green screen i think it's just
because he's doing a zoom call or
something right
but it does kind of look like he's
sitting in a green screen why did
america elect
grandpa who should be in a nursing home
in new york city
because of hatred because of their
hatred for donald trump
they voted for him out of hatred and now
they got an idiot his pr no he's not
native he's just old as well
what if the simulation is just breaking
you know like like you ever see the rick
and morty episode where they turn the
the simulation computing power down
for jerry to like five percent and then
nobody is talking but he believes it
like people are saying
yes and my man like they're not actually
interacting with him
but he just thinks it's all real like
we're sitting here and joe biden's like
i'll answer your questions now the
camera turns off and we're like oh
that's normal
there are americans thinking that's
normal that's the weirdest thing to me
what who are you you peop you you all
sitting there listening to this podcast
you people
you people you you podcast listeners oh
yeah how many of you are sitting there
going like
well that was normal no is anybody
thinking that
only only people who are willingly
convincing themselves to believe
unreality so that they can get rid of
orange man bad
all this fits with something that i said
here uh back in november
which is that the the democratic people
were just beaten into submission
yeah and they and now they're willing to
accept total insanity oh yeah
in order to just relieve the pressure
like jennifer rubin
right from the washington post the other
day she tweets out she's like
it's such a great day where i don't have
to think about politics on the weekend
or whatever
i'm sleeping in late sleeping in late so
even she
is like feeling the relief of not being
beaten over the head all day by horrible
horrible terrible things
and it's like man what is that this
something that is
this is the you don't know what that is
jack yeah you wear this thing and it
protects you from covid
it's like i don't know it has a vent on
it yeah can you put it on with the
headphones on the same time i don't
think so but i'll show you did you see
the the people with the big green
plastic boxes over there no don't
don't that's the new normal don't say
people say pod people
children animals oh yeah those are
children
in school my friend i just saw two
people in the woods with them on
no so for people who are just listening
and can't see
like what's happening ian is wearing
this weird like space
you got to turn it on otherwise they
tell me it's on now it's fogging up
it's venting for me ian's wearing this
big plastic
space helmet dome thing that we have
it's going to protect me from coving
and a living apparently that's it that's
it the crazy thing is you joe biden
just said apparently uh i i at some kind
of like uh
you know interestingly they're saying he
didn't do a press conference but he has
answered questions
because he was asked about uh by a
journalist about how long were to be
locked down he said i can't give you an
answer but maybe this time next year
next year right at the same time greg
abbott completely opens up texas
mississippi
i believe florida's already open forget
it it's like
man well let's let's go back to that
point you were making about
maybe there's a security issue because
we have this story from bloomberg
warnings of uh warnings of another
capital attack raised tensions in
washington
bloomberg's reporting that law
enforcement warnings that a militia
group may be plotting to attack the u.s
capitol on thursday
raised tensions again in washington and
helped prompt the house to cancel plans
to meet for votes that could explain why
joe biden has not given a state of the
union address as you mentioned
quote we have obtained intelligence that
shows a possible plot to breach the
capital by an identified militia group
on thursday march 4th
the u.s capitol police said in a
statement wednesday we are taking the
intelligence seriously
that alert followed a joint intelligence
bulletin late tuesday from the homeland
security department
and the federal bureau of investigation
about extremists discussing
carrying out attacks at the capitol from
march 4th to march 6th
melissa smith lova a senior homeland
security official told two senate
committees
about the threat on wednesday the police
warning did not give specifics citing
sensitive nature of the information now
now what's this all about why is a
militia going to be storming in well
bloomberg says
true inauguration day representative
michael mccall
a texas republican told cnn wednesday
that trump has a responsibility to
defuse the threat
by telling his supporters to stand down
quote this threat is credible mccall
said it's real
the march 4 timing coincides with the
date linked to conspiracy theories
about it being the true inauguration day
presidents were sworn in on that date
until the 20th amendment to the
constitution shifted the ceremony to
january 20th 1920 in 1933.
the warnings also come after capitol
police and federal law enforcement came
under severe criticism
for not acting faster on intelligence
than uh
that the gen 6 protests could turn
violent the latest warnings
caught many in washington by surprise
because they came after a day
they came out a day after acting
sergeant-at-arms timothy blodgett
told lawmakers that capitol police had
no indication groups would travel to
washington
to protest or commit acts of violence
now i'll tell you this they're saying
there's going to be 5
000 national guards still there they're
keeping the fences in the razor wire
i said nothing was going gonna happen
that was i i was saying it i said i
think nothing's gonna happen i think if
people do show up it's gonna be a bunch
of people waving little american flags
are gonna go home like conservatives do
and i published a video on january 6 at
1 pm where i was like nothing's
happening it's boring trump is speaking
people are going to go home
the session's happening it's over
everybody and then literally
when that video went live it was like
trump supporters have pushed past the
barricade
than 110 they're attacking the cops and
i was like oh well
i was wrong i was absolutely wrong about
that yeah but you know the circumstances
are completely different
you know a militia well first of all
what militia
second of all where did you hear about
this because if it wasn't on parlor
was it on facebook yeah no no if it was
on facebook why is facebook still up
well because facebook is special yeah of
course no they're trying to get facebook
down
in some way too yeah like the left has
been going nuts against facebook buzz
i think was buzzfeed wrote an article
where they're like this is where the
insurrection was planned
and then it was like number number one
is gan number two is parlor or whatever
and then number five it said facebook
yup that's right
facebook and they've been attacking
facebook nonstop over it
facebook was where the groups existed
where they were talking about you know
doing this and facebook didn't do
anything about it
well if they have credible information
and they're monitoring it why haven't
they been talking about where this is
chat this chatter's happening how do we
shut this down how do we
prohibit this this is a completely
different environment
there's literally thousands of
arm troops razor wire unscalable
fences an impenetrable uh perimeter
there no one is coming
with small arms into the distance to do
right it's to walk into a building and
be like by standing here
i'm on it's a glue that makes me you
know you can't you can't arrest me i'm
the president now
that's not how a country works no and
biden along that vein biden doesn't need
to be
in the capitol to do a a talk to
congress that's the good point
he could be this is the thing we need a
creative person
in in in that position i think andrew
yang would have been a great great
example of that he was super creative
and you need to be working with the
technology we have
to to explain and help people and i mean
it's just so ridiculous so
no no no yeah you're right that negates
the devil's advocate point you're making
yeah i hated that i hated it hated doing
it joe biden could
give a speech from space right yeah well
unfortunately survive orbit but you know
the launch to
he could take his phone and hold it up
and be like hey how's it going america
you know
peace just like you know my americans
you know everything's good see you then
people would like him so much better if
he did is this thing on
is it on nancy is it on this you stumble
on is it on yeah
jill biden walks up and smacks him on
the butt like like with elizabeth warren
remember that
dude that was that was messed up
remember what happened elizabeth warren
was doing was trying to be like aoc and
it was the cringiest thing ever
and she's doing an instagram live
thinking it's going to connect with
young people
and she's like talking to people and
she's like i'm going to go get me a
beer right i'm going to take a beer now
and then but hold on this is crazy
because she's drinking the beer and her
husband walks up while she's streaming
and he smacked her on the butt
and she like jumps and then she said
something she said i'm glad you're here
i'm happy that you're here and then
trump tweeted probably the funniest
thing he's ever tweeted he goes what do
you mean you're glad he's there he's
supposed to be there it's his house that
was just a great drink
i loved it yeah no but a lot of people
are responding to this bloomberg thing
saying
dude no this is ridiculous it's the
democrats just being like help help the
sky is falling 1-6 it's the end of the
world oh the militias are coming for us
we've always been at war with the white
domestic terrorists in the united states
and you gotta the military-industrial
complex will use
any any possible evidence to to enhance
the mil
the militant nature of the society to
gain security powers yeah we got to be
careful about it it's not it's not just
the military industrial complex it's
just
it's this it's the the revolving door
between them and government it's the
government agencies their contractors
and the weapons manufacturers are all
sitting there being like
well i like blowing stuff up yeah don't
you like getting paid to stand there
with a gun
i hire my contractors and they'll guard
you for no no reason
because you're afraid i think standing
there with the gun is more like what the
national guard is doing right now enemy
no disrespect in the national guard
like the the blackwater types what is
that company called now they keep
changing the name because of the
controversies
they're the guys who like they go in and
do the real messed up stuff
you know and i wonder man because i i
hear this stuff a lot from
people who who support that kind of
action that military action they're like
yeah well you wouldn't be living half as
good as you are right now
if these guys weren't going out there
and doing this stuff blackwater private
contractors killing people in the middle
east
absolutely oh yeah there are people who
believe like if we're not doing that
you know the petro dollar falls and then
we collapse and then we're
you know that's it what is america
export man
war culture culture maybe culture
culture is probably one of the biggest
exports debt
that's our biggest tech support yeah
well so
we had we had uh ethan supply on the
show and he mentioned
what a lot of people don't realize about
this war is that we're propping up the
petro dollar
yeah we can go into debt with as much
money as we want because
we're pointing guns at everybody
basically so
they got to use our dollars no matter
what it could inflate things for
americans but the economy can't collapse
as long as we got guns pointed at people
so that's i mean that's the whole that's
the big picture i guess blackwater is
called academy now
are you sure it's called academy now i
thought they changed that it's just
academy with an i
not academy now that'd be funny um
before that it was called zxe
they changed it from blackwater to z in
2009 and then to academy in 2001. why do
they keep changing it to avoid
bad press monsanto did the same thing
that allowed itself to be bought by bear
you remember when marlborough changed
their name to altria as well
it sounds like a medicine right exactly
i mean i don't know
i don't know who to believe i don't know
where to put my attention i just want to
know
who is pulling the strings who's the one
that's saying to biden
don't talk who's one saying maybe you
shouldn't do a joint session who's the
one saying no state of the union
one of the coolest things about being
president has got to be doing the state
of the union when you get 500 people
standing up
cheering for you national television 40
million people it's got to be a
highlight i bet you bill clinton when he
first got elected i bet he was like man
i can't wait to get this thing done
he did his first one what like 28 days
whatever after inauguration
just enough time to get the speech
written to prepare
to practice a whole bunch to get the
logistics down he was probably let's do
it let's do it let's do it he probably
wanted to do it the next day
february february 17th february 17th
yeah less than a month later yep
less than a month later and joe biden
now in this time of
of healing when are you going to heal me
joe yeah come on joe
come on fat heal me you know you know i
was thinking
what do you think the british crown
thought of the founding fathers
dangerous far-right extremists
terrorists
sovereign citizens and
under what authority did the founding
fathers have to actually declare
independence
god yeah literally
literally it's like in the first what a
few seconds well no actually there were
there were a series of elections held
in each state and then some of them were
like ad hoc and like unofficial
and then they sent representatives to
varying degrees they were supported by
this they were down at the pub and
they're like
who's going to go to philadelphia i know
it's kind of crazy
but then imagine this imagine if right
now check it out check it out it's
awesome
what if there was a very large group
what does that what does it keepers have
like 40 000 or something like that oh i
don't know
what happens if just a bunch of armed
groups in various states said
yeah we were elected by our communities
we represent them so we're we're
we're voting for this they better have a
good document to back it up
that's one of the things the founding
fathers had they were really smart and
good
what was it they had a list of what was
it fourteen grievances
they were upset about was it fourteen
and redresses yeah yeah
whatever that whatever that means you
gotta fix it yeah the 18th century and
they were also
really wealthy a lot of them like landon
it'd be like if elon musk came together
with jeff bezos
with mark zuckerberg with us you know so
so was it our oligarchs at the time
no they weren't the kings of industry
that's true
they were just well-off dudes for the
most part right it's not quite like
zuckerberg and
well but there was an industry per se
yeah there was the east india trading
company why i guess company to ever
exist i'm pretty sure
right but sure certainly but this is
pre-industrial revolution this is
pre-robber barons this is pre
mass wealth of every you know these are
gentlemen farmers
right some lawyers some some army guys
right uh legislators you know yeah
uh and so it wasn't the same kind of
power i don't think but i do remember
studying the american revolution
recently actually and seeing the fusion
between what was called the cosmopolitan
folks
you know like the people that lived in
the city that were all educated the guys
that went and lived in
france and came back they had to make an
alliance with
the religious zionists who lived
in the the countryside right like there
were can people in there still are here
in the united states who believe that
this is new zion that this is
this is a place to build oh yeah oh yeah
this is a place to build
zion and and have new kingdom of god
here in the united states
and they were able to link up these
networks the cosmopolitan guys worried
about the natural rights and the
freedoms and this and that and the
taxation and all that
they they joined forces with the
religious folks who believe that this
was
zion and that they were here to build a
new promised land
and they got together because they all
wanted their independence so they had
alignment this was like an early
example of a decentralized movement
that had alignment right because john
adams and thomas jefferson were
they weren't zionists right but they saw
they had common
alignment there so they were like all
right let's do it and i've read sermons
actually
from like 1760 and 1770
from preachers in the countryside
telling their people about this
revolution that's coming because god
wants it because
we're here to build new zion et cetera
et cetera and
it's just interesting to me to as we're
talking about this is to see who were
the characters
like what did they have what they hold
what kind of power did they have and
what was their motivation
what is what would be the analogy today
uh i don't know man i don't think i
don't think it's musk or bezos
but i think about a lot that invoking
god when i'm talking about
this and the problems and the solutions
like it gets people
rallied and it's kind of scary to use
that because i feel like it's like not
fair
it's it's kind of like playing the trump
card you know and
it's almost like i don't necessarily
believe i don't know if there's a god
necessarily i just don't know
but to say it it works there are people
who will absolutely
pretend to be acting on behalf of god
because they know that people will be
scared or people will be faithful and
they'll give power to these individuals
who exploit them
that's what i see when i see i'll put it
this way
the republicans i think are you know
mitch mcconnell looks at
all these conservatives and goes well
who else you're going to vote for
and the democrats are like well i'll say
literally anything to you to get you to
vote for me because i know as soon as
you do you walk away
now things are a little bit different
though with social media seeing these
memes come from the left and the right
making fun of biden
the greatest meme ever made in my
opinion right now
you see the one where it's big words
it's it's the red button in the blue
button yeah and says vaporizing syrians
the blue one says two thousand dollar
checks instead of the guy being sweating
and confused which to
which to press it's dr robotnik laughing
maniacally as he reaches for the red
button
and it says joe biden over it yep it's
perfect because not only does the meme
work by itself but it's also a meta meme
in that by getting rid of the confused
sweating guy and replacing with an
enthusiastic robotnik reaching for the
red button so assuredly
it's just masterpiece masterpiece meme
but i want to point something about the
founding fathers the one thing they had
the biggest advantage king was three
thousand miles away
yep what was he gonna do about it they
were having these meetings they were
kicking their feet up now the regulars
were going around and and acting a fool
but for the most part when the when the
cat is away the mice will play
that's the saying right yeah so the king
wouldn't come into the
colonies and then we brought i brought
this up many times they could write this
letter being like yo
king we out and they send it on a ship
three months later the king gets it and
he's like oh
hurrah i'm gonna write a strongly worded
letter back to them
three months later it makes it back and
it's been now six months
since they declared independence and
they're acting as a sovereign nation at
this point so they're like bro that was
six months ago where you been
right right we don't have that right now
they had the whole lantern thing all
set up one was that one by land two if i
see
yep they were prepared they were super
bad they said they sent that letter off
they're like let's put some lanterns in
please
to signify if the british were coming by
land or by sea i've probably
landed i'm probably getting all my
history wrong right my girlfriend's at
home right now watching this being like
your history is not right
sorry baby they basically had like the
beacon set up so like when you see the
regulars light the beacons
and then you know they put little
lanterns in yeah they also in addition
to having
the distance um in the time buffer they
had the french
which were like this giant monarch
nation that was willing to go to war for
them basically to destroy england
yeah well kind of they were basically
like war with england so
we're not really helping you so much as
you're helping us yeah symbiotic
and men they would have had no chance
without the french the french basically
bankrupted their economy yeah and
and then and then it caused the french
revolution and then you know that guy
who executed all those other guys
but there were a bunch of nobles in
france who were like i regret that
decision
hey i don't i'm glad they did it but
yeah they destroyed their economy
and then everybody started starving and
the french revolution other issues okay
and then we got louisiana yeah there you
go
right yeah so it's what like uh 25 years
later
less wow yeah not just louise
yeah and then i think there was that big
swath of mexico
and then you know where the california
territory and then texas
declared independence and then texas
signed a treaty joining the united
states
i i was reading something about how
texas could have been five different
states
it was it was five different nations
within the texas republic
republic really yeah right so and then
uh and and i think this is recently an
anniversary maybe of their independence
from mexico
yesterday yesterday so i saw i looked at
the document
right they were really good with the
documents back then uh and
they're still good well i guess we're
even better with the documents these
days
but it made me think texans texas folks
mexicans they're put they're people of
color people from texas
are people of color they're actually
immigrants to the united states when are
we going to start treating texas
with the dignity and respect that we ex
we need in demand to give our immigrant
folks here
in the united states and refer to them
as poc and give them all the
opportunities and all the affirmative
action
and all the benefits and honors of
regime designed around
benefiting pocs and immigrants and
people new to the country
when are the texas republic folks going
to get their dues well let's let's let's
talk about texas
all right for most of you you may have
heard texas greg abbott comes right out
and he's like yo
we done yep no more covet lockdown
what's that look on your face it's like
hell yeah man
i'm into it let's do it good i'm ready
to go and what did joe biden say
he called him the neanderthals joe biden
neanderthal thinking biden calls
abbott's decision to open texas lift
mask
order big mistake you know why joe biden
won't do anything about it
this the risk of secession is real
it's real it is i'm not it's not my
opinion that is the opinion
of casey michael writing for nbc
pro-trump republican secession rhetoric
in texas and elsewhere is more than a
punchline
this kind of seditious rhetoric would
spell disaster for the supposedly united
states of america
in this article yes dude goes in i mean
look i think it's
i think i actually actually agree with
them
when they say that the risk of secession
is legit now they mention
that there have been many instances
where republicans are like we will
secede from the union if
you know obama gets elected this time's
different and so
we talked about there's uh five counties
in oregon have you heard this
uh what the whole greater idaho greater
items and then you got like nine or
whatever counties in northern california
to make the state of jefferson
some of those might actually join
greater idaho then you've got weld
county
and uh what's what's what's the other
one oh that i think that's it these are
counties there's a handful of counties
in virginia that have been welcomed into
the state of west virginia right as well
really
yeah but it you can't do that like you
might not well there needs to be federal
approval no why well at least according
to the documents
the laws you can't you can't redraw
state borders without federal approval
you know that's a really good point jack
and you are correct you need the
approval of your sovereign leader
and your legal system before you're
allowed to declare independence
just like in 1776 when the founding
fathers i have
you're mocking me they sent a petition
they sent a petition to parliament
and parliament said good good sir the
americans have requested independence
okay why do we agree
stamp sent it back to them that works
like anybody that's ever gone through a
legal process
knows you first you have to start off
with a nice letter then you have to come
with a
nasty letter then you have to come with
a demand letter then you have to demand
mediation
arbitration then finally you're like on
guard
yes that's true though the founding
fathers didn't immediately just say yo
we out
they were like they were good kings sir
we have a list of issues
we have a list of grievances and then
they kept kicking back
for like 20 years they were like yo dude
this is a problem for us and the king
was like i don't care
so now what we're seeing is i was
looking at these counties that want to
succeed
joe biden calls texas a neanderthal
that's very racist by the way
subhuman that's neanderthals were people
and that is an extremely racist thing to
say
speechless truth that's a good point
it's terrible that's really really
expected of him to say that
joe biden won't do anything because the
risk is real so
you know he he said you go you know joe
biden
said we're gonna uh be locked down no no
normal
until this time next year right tax is
sad
door's open do something basically the
same day
yeah right you know why you know why
nothing will happen taxes are going to
be fine they can do whatever they want
what do you think would happen if joe
biden said i hereby order a mandate
that taxes lock back down what would
happen everything would happen
that would be the final straw would
would the federal government send in dhs
or national guard to enforce this
lockdown
no they wouldn't you know why they don't
have enough
people they don't if the people in texas
are told by the governor you open your
business they will
if joe biden tries sending people into
texas to shut down
their businesses down the police in
texas will stop them
we've already seen what was it like in
ohio where they said like we'll arrest
atf members for violating
our gun laws if you try and confiscate a
weapon from somebody
in violation of our law will arrest you
when
if if the federal government tries to
over exert its authority
i mean it may have the authority i
welcome that actually
i welcome that yeah well as as as a as
a necessary mistake on the path
to continue decentralization like we
have a serious centralization problem
biden is an integral mistake on all and
all
biology in in in our economy
in science and technology in finance
with currencies
we have a centralization problem right
because when it's all in the middle it's
huge risks
yeah you saw the federal reserve go down
oh yeah that was crazy
so we decentralization of authority
is actually on trend with everything
else that's happening right now
strategic disconnection has been my
theme for the last couple of years
i would welcome this type of egregious
behavior
on the part of the federal government as
part of a necessary step
to increase this decency this is why
this is why trump probably didn't do
anything when it came to black lives
matter as well
it wasn't so much that people will say
you're a tyrant
it was that you had riots all over the
country nowhere near enough federal
federal law enforcement to actually stop
it now
that's not entirely correct it's correct
that it would have taken a substantial
amount of federal force
to stop them and it may have backfired
and then the resulting backlash could
have overwhelmed
national guard or but it was also
consistent with trump's response to
covid
as well yeah leaving into the states
leave it up to the states
but so in this in this regard you have a
very bold move by mississippi and by
texas but texas is legit like we're
opening back up
well florida's already been open so
let's be real joe biden's not going to
do anything because joe biden doesn't
really care
when joe biden comes out this is the
crazy thing he's only the leader of the
blue states
this is the point that people need to
realize that is the scariest point of
all
florida already is open many states
never lock down
texas is reopening defying joe biden joe
biden has
no confidence in red states the reds
have no confidence in joe biden
but the blue states are like whenever
you say biden it's true
so biden comes out as the president of
the united states says we got to stay
locked down don't be stupid and the red
states are like
no make me yeah yeah so think about who
is he actually in charge of
not the red states they don't seem to
care ron desantis is ragging on the guy
he's doing whatever he wants and then
what did biden say craziest story we've
seen in a long time
biden threatened travel restrictions
into florida because of what rhonda
sanchez was doing and ron desantis was
like
bring it so this is not the president of
the united states he's the president of
the blue states
he is and and i know legally and all
that stuff he was inaugurated the
problem i'm talking about is the
division between
the tribes in this country south dakota
we're not locking down florida we're not
locking down texas mississippi
now i think louisiana is diseasing
restrictions they're basically looking
at biden and saying
no imagine maybe this is why they
haven't done the state of the union
ladies and gentlemen i'm here to tell
you that the state of the union is weak
pathetic there's actually no union
and i'm here and i'm just leading
however many was like whatever few
handfuls you know
the the states the electoral states that
he got elected that's it i'm not
i'm not the president for everybody else
that i mean that would have to be
that's that's like the reality in the in
the article before about the militia
attack
there's the you know fbi director chris
chris ray says domestic extremists pose
the greatest threat to the us or
whatever right
he's not wrong from his perspective he's
the establishment perspective
he views the the intelligence agencies
the security state
and the corporate politicians as the
legitimate united states government
and donald trump is not that he was a
usurper
he was an invader he was outsider so
they were like
this guy is taking over our legitimate
system he's a threat
now think about these people these
people who are supposedly threatening
the us
they're not foreigners they're not uh
swearing allegiance to anything other
than the constitution in the
constitution
these are american citizens at odds with
the existing
establishment you got yourselves a
problem the existing establishment is an
occupying force that does not believe in
the constitution of the united states
and the people here in the united states
that do believe in the constitution and
do believe in the vision of the founders
there are when i say instructionists
i mean that in the context of there is a
dominant
occupying force that has captured all of
our institutions
captured all the universities the
government everything
and they do not adhere to or believe in
the constitution of the united states
or in freedom of liberty or in
individual accountability or any of the
things that we were founded on
therefore they are an occupying foreign
force and people that believe in the
constitution
are actually insurgents because we do
want to expel
well it's occupying force this is the uh
white pill moment
you know that means like the optimism
it's the it's the good news it's the
it's it's the
hope yeah bring it bring it no black
filling here the hope is
uh is in front of us joe biden has lost
control he can't even answer questions
about someone turning as a camera off
the establishment is in free fall the
democrat
the the democrats and republicans the
establishment politician politicians
are flailing wildly in panic turning the
president's camera off
wow they are scared abandoning tradition
of addressing the congress and
addressing the people after you've been
elected president of each other and what
do you think
and then when he tries to come out
saying we gotta we gotta stay locked
down and all the states are just
breaking away and saying
dude f you dude and what do you think
happens if joe biden goes
uh my my fellow americans we must uh ban
uh uh
firearms what do you think texas is
gonna say yeah
they're gonna start yosemite salmon
[Music]
very irresponsible the economy yosemite
sam
white red beard just kidding but why do
you somebody sam have a little
kind of had a beard like you john what
do you mean i'm just kidding he had a
white southern accent can't we no you
just now
cancel yosemite anyway um when
i say when the economy crashes because
as you study history you see it's a
cyclical crash and rebuilding crash
that wait didn't it just crash this year
2008 it looked
yeah it's crashing we're in a crash
right now basically if you look at the
numbers
you don't need to look at the numbers
yeah like just look at the people who
don't have jobs and the crashes can take
years sometimes you know what you know
what's funny you know it's funny there's
like every decade there's a crash
like something happens we had the
mortgage-backed security crisis and all
of a sudden it was like ah the market's
on fire
trump's economy was so good the only
thing that caused the crash was when
governments were like
turn the economy off that's exactly and
they turned the key and just stopped it
that's exactly that's what's the only
way they could stop it that's the only
way they could stop
the best economy ever with with also the
greatest
quarter of growth in american history
yeah
it's like 30 some percent i can't tell
you how many times i talked to somebody
i had a i was
at a contractor working this back at the
other studio and he was like
2019 is the great was the greatest year
of my life i've never made that much
money before
yeah and i was at it i was at i i told
this before i was buying furniture for
the studio setup
so this is beginning of 2020 the lady
who was selling furniture
i was like we got to do a big order we
need tables we need chairs we need desks
we need everything we're building out
this whole thing
it was a very expensive order and she
was laughing and then i was like
good day for you hunchy goes it's been a
good year
and i was like yeah how was last year
last year was good for you and she goes
i've never made more money in my life
she said last year was my biggest year
ever selling furniture and she was just
laughing having a good time
that was a trump economy but i could
print 10 times the money and pay you 10
times the value but then everything
that was before dude that was before
2008 m1 has been going no but but but
what's happened in 2020 it's
unprecedented okay so it was going like
this it was going like this and then
truly dude
the whole scale from this part shrinks
now because it just goes like this
so my point is when this seems like
we're headed towards a crash that's like
the last semblance of unity
in the united states obviously we have
our lockdown issues in the states by
state state rights but when that's gone
this money thing the bitcoin the crypto
people are going to come up and
basically take control of the country
it's going to need a document we have
the constitution bill of rights and we
need something like that the manila
principle so we need
a we need a con a digital
constitutional convention that's and i i
mean this in in no way
challenging any sort of us just
basically getting people from various
industries and various regions
to write down what they think matters
most
to the people where they live and who
they represent
so that we can draft we should start
with like 30 principles
of what the internet is supposed to
grant to people as as an economy
as a communication hub as entertainment
then we
go through them we whittle down the
language and then find a good
thing the manila principles have you
heard of them you should pull them up
there's like six of them
it's basically an internet bill of
rights it's real it's been done and i
would love for you to pull it up and
read it right now well so
uh i wanna i wanna make this point
though when you mention that the bitcoin
people are going to be the ones who take
over yeah it's going to be like the fall
of the soviet union
so so that's right that's right so i i
was talking to a friend of mine
because everybody knows now i have a
friend in ukraine i mention her all the
time
and i was like well it was really
interesting i went there and i was you
know you live you were born
in the soviet union you were a little
kid when the soviet union collapsed
how did these oligarchs come to power in
these past couple of decades when
everybody was under the boot of russia
she was like they're gangsters they were
criminal gangsters
and then look look at this way you have
a power plant right power plant waits
for the word
from their higher militaristic communist
authority
when the soviet union collapsed that
communication got snapped
just the line was cut now the guy
running his power plant's like
i don't know all of a sudden the dude
walks in he's got three dudes around him
with guns
and he goes we're going to tell you what
to do it's our factory now
you answer to me and the foreman of the
factory goes sounds good to me because i
don't know what's going on
these guys went around from building the
building with guns and just kept saying
it's mine it's mine it's mine
and then all sudden boom they were
billionaires overnight the kleptocracy
as it's called yeah yeah so what will
happen when the dollar
gets smacked down why do you think china
has been buying so much bitcoin
or printing and mining i should say
mining bitcoin because
what is that what's that face well i
just didn't i see an article recently
about china shutting down all kinds of
mining operations yeah but it's a very
clever thing because of the price tanks
and then they buy it all up and then
they say oh no we're just kidding oh
okay yeah they've done it several times
and i think india did it it's very
clever they're like we're gonna ban this
and then everyone panic sells
and then guess who buys it up there are
a lot of people right now
who have already become worth hundreds
of millions of dollars
there's one really funny tweet i saw
some guy said looking at my account with
15 bitcoin in it on the computer that i
lost or whatever
and it's just like because you can
actually see the number you can see
the the the uh the address right in the
blockchain and he's like that's mine but
i can't get it
there are a lot of people who have
bitcoin they maybe even bought in with a
couple hundred bucks
and now it's at like 50 grand 50 grand
that it is in your faces man we are
watching the value of the dollar
evaporate one of the craziest stories i
saw did you know that fast food
prices have been skyrocketing nobody
noticed this people don't pay attention
because we're frogs boiling in a pot
i was reading a story about how the cost
of fast food meals in the past year have
gone up like 40 or 50 percent wow
yeah restaurants have also skyrocketed
and there's a graph showing the cost of
food going up
it's getting it's happening 49 crunchy
tacos a taco bell oh man
39 come on bro i remember five
mcdonald's cheeseburgers for two bucks
yeah wow because i'm old i already
established this
remember the dollar menu dude
so what are they now they're like eleven
dollar meals happy meals
yeah yeah so so like uh what's like
yeah they are like a big mac's 529 or
something i'm gonna stop in on the way
home i'm gonna i'm gonna probably
i'm probably you better yeah do it in
new york city you know how much of a
number one's gonna cost in new york
probably like 15 bucks 20 bucks
in new york city no that's it and that's
before a 15
minimum wage yep there you go so listen
listen
ian makes a good point the people who
are holding bitcoin are going to wake up
one day and be the new oligarchs
definitely but we have a constitution so
it'll be different than russia as long
as we adhere to it
and the manila principles which is like
a digital i think we can integrate it
into our u.s constitution
um well well let's let's i could read
something well we'll we'll pull that up
in a bit
maybe there's six i've got i wanna i
wanna talk about something else because
i think this matters
biden slashes stimulus checks for
americans making more than eighty
thousand dollars
president bows to pressure from moderate
democrats and will hand out fewer direct
payments than under trump
fewer than under trump which moderate
democrats are like this
but just can i just kind of talk about
how brutal it must be to have voted for
joe biden
thinking the democrats were gonna get
you this check and now you're being told
by the news actually trump was trying to
get you more
that is gotta be like a kick in the
waltz
you know those tweets where people are
like you know you sure are
like you know spending a lot of money
when you owe me money right
yeah it's like these switches like you
sure are you know vaporizing syrians
when you owe me a lot of money a lot of
serious biden's uh
sure got a lot of money for somebody who
owes me two thousand dollars
exactly you sure got a lot of money for
missiles yeah it's like
how insane is it we're the only country
in the world where they force everybody
out of their jobs and stay home and then
don't give them any money to make it
look like this i pulled this meme up
fine
i didn't make it i just saw people
sharing it and i reposted it i don't
know who made it
it's yours now it is the hand pushing
one of the two buttons
vaporizing sirians is red and two is
another text is blue and then it's dr
robotnik jim carrey going
and pressing the red button joe biden
all the democrats said
vote for the democrats two thousand
dollar check donald trump said
two thousand dollar check mitch
mcconnell was like well slow around
there
trump so the republicans said no
the democrats said yes and everyone said
i'll vote for the democrats
and then the democrats it's it's it's
wonderful it's like
they gave they all voted to give the one
ring to joe biden
and they followed him into the fires you
know of mount doom
and then they're like cast the two
thousand dollar checks into the mailbox
and then biden turns around and goes no
and then walks out with the money and
then hands them to a military-industrial
complex guy and then press the button
and fires missiles
and goes kills kids or whatever i think
what you said earlier about us being
co-op that our government being
basically occupied
is is it's extremely astute like after
woodrow wilson signed the federal
reserve act and basically sold us out to
this power and then
after world war ii when the they made
the liberal economic order
and established these military bases all
over the world uh
it's like a parasite in the brain of our
country it's crazy slow down there ron
paul
i love ron paul ron this is for you
that's right
we still so for christmas luke put ron
paul on top of the tree
because he's both a star and an angel
and now now the picture is just like on
the window ron paul's amazing guy
and i always tell people that the reason
have you seen that video that's going
viral from 1988
yes of course where him on more on more
not more amory
no no no no i don't know it was just one
of those shock jock hoes right
from that time period so ron paul is a
legend
he's amazing and then he's like yeah and
by the way you
fatty you should lose some weight too no
no he was like the government can't make
you a good person
why don't they why don't they put you on
a diet you're a little overweight and
the guy's like oh how dare you
it's a good point i'm a doctor it's he
isn't yeah he's probably right
the government can't make you be a good
person so i'm thinking about
this parasite in the brain of our
country and how do you remove a parasite
without it killing the host because this
is parasite
blue goo that's blue right you can't
yank it out because it will kill the
host
you can't you can try and kill it but if
it knows you're trying to kill it it
will kill the host
likely so you need to subvert it you
need to massage the affected area until
it starts
wiggling its way out and then you get
the forceps and you slowly pull very
very slowly otherwise it could rip and
then retreat back in
yeah so you make the host less enticing
to the parasite
so we have to poison pill ourselves or
will
no there's there's no real analogy for
that i think you know
create a system that's not conducive to
the parasite
i don't think that's a good analogy
because it's one planet
it would be like if there was one host
and literally no other host i think the
us
has been is the host the us government i
think the whole planet is basically got
a bunch of powerful interests that
collude with each other for a variety of
reasons you're right the british
government too
yeah it's not like it's funny how people
are like you're a conspiracy theorist
it's not a conspiracy i think there's
international businesses that do deals
with each other that's happening
yeah right and so you've got trump being
like he comes out into the
by the white house or the helicopter
whatever and the press asks him like
what's going on he goes we're going to
be selling a ton of weapons to saudi
arabia it's great we're going to make
tons of money it's great for the economy
and it's like it's right there in your
face he's saying it
i love that by the way it was one of the
greatest moments of trump's presidency
watching all the all the anti-war left
just go like
he just said it he said all the
questions
my favorite tweet ever was this
journalist who's like i have been
working on this story for a year
all year and he just says it he just
says it like
he just tweeted it out he just tweeted
it out
that was huge that was huge that was
right around the same time as let's do a
little game theory
oh man so i i do think
think about this when we got off the
gold standard
it's really amazing once once the the
banking institutions
i i think it's silly to say the banks
are in charge or the fed there's clearly
just people in power and wealthy
interests who just use these machines in
these systems
to maintain control yeah the bank for
international settlements
it's it's it's it's like the mother
brand you know the bis
the liberal economic order you called it
yeah they've established it in like 1946
i think right after world war ii to make
sure that there was no world war three
yeah and they were like we're going to
use the british and the american
governments to establish military
dominance on the planet isn't that a
good isn't it a good thing to do without
world war ii according to kissinger yes
and so we're just going to do limited
wars it will avoid a hot total war
but you can see that it's i think the
time for limited war is over
it served its purpose we did avert world
war three wait are you advocating now
for total war
no i'm advocating for no war i don't
think we need war anymore i mean we're
we're getting
into a place we're talking about all the
time violence doesn't work anymore yeah
you become the villain instantly when
you engage in that stuff
we're getting there we're molecularly
printing you know water and food we'll
be able to do that pretty soon
so we're very close we've got to build
them replicators
and that's it but but i will say too
that's it we're almost there qed
post scarcity bro post scarcity people
are printing food
we already live in an abundant world
just looking at all of the fat people in
america
yep we live in a world of abundance
we're designed to live in a world of
scarcity this is the one thing i try to
hammer into my kids brains
constantly bro what not just fat people
fat homeless people right we have people
who are homeless
and morbidly obese that's that's like
that's i don't know if it's a testament
to capitalism or like
a a detriment you know or it's a
it's a prime example of the way our
society is evolved faster than our
physical
physical being right we we we are
creatures of worlds of scarcity
now living in a world of abundance and
we just don't know how to operate right
we don't operate ironically think about
this a man with chiseled eight pack
like you yeah not right now but by
summertime i promise
uh get that beachbody that's a sign of
status to appear as though you're
emaciated
yeah like what is that has the world
turned up but these are
these guys these guys who do the the
like the photo shoots of the super
muscles and everything
they dehydrate themselves oh yeah of
course you have to drop a lot of the
water so that the muscles come through
the skin better
yeah and there was top down lighting is
always really healthy i was i was i
think i was reading something from jason
moma who was aquaman
and he posted a picture something
happened where like he was at the beach
and they posted a photo saying he's
really let himself go and he literally
didn't he was still doing the training
program he was just like
it's crazy that you think just like
having skin and looking this way
having like hydrated skin you think is
letting yourself go because they're so
used to these movies
where they're like emaciated let me just
say one thing if you've ever seen
brad pitt and fight club thor with this
shirt off for a second or the wolverine
or whatever just know
that those guys they train like six
months for that one day
for that one shot where they have their
shirt off and that is not real and that
is not sustained and that's with guys
that are on steroids
with personal trainers and personal
chefs and they can only maintain that
for just a few days
for that photo shoot and i think it's
totally unrealistic i think hemsworth
who plays thor said he was eating like
several pounds of fish and chicken every
day because you need that much protein
to maintain the mass
and then they do the sh they film the
movie over the month and then he goes to
a lighter
you know training thing where he's not
you know breaking himself back to a
normal guy
gerard butler his training for 300 he
played leonidas is amazing i think
there's a youtube
short 10 minute video about it's really
powerful nevertheless it is interesting
how we need to adapt to a world of
abundance when we're uh
accustomed to a world of scarcity yeah
good point so you
we're brainwashed we basically to think
that there's not enough
not brainwashed through all time and
history
there has not been enough and now you
can order any vegetable any fruit
more or less on the internet i mean
that's a problem it is it seems like it
has become a problem it is a problem
it's a problem that you can order
strawberries in winter
because they got to grow them in like
mexico and then put them on a freight
and then ship it all the way out
it's it's it's a huge waste of energy
for a luxury
it's a luxury i get it it's great but
in that capacity i think people should
get back to like
we need to get back people should put
chickens on the like you know we gotta
get chickens man
you buy a chicken with rose i saw a
tweet yeah i'm all about it let's get
some chickens we got uh so this is this
is my shout out to all the people who
are upset about joe biden and the
stimulus check and i think that's like
the
what we're starting the segment off with
you can get mad the government's not
gonna give you that money
but what are you gonna do about it what
are you gonna do you're gonna sit there
and be like i'm mad
all right here's a solution you gotta be
self-sustainable i don't want a solution
and that's fine you can be mad if you
want but then you're gonna be hungry and
mad
you could sell an instagram account buy
baseball gloves and resell them at
retail
yeah or shoes or or united cic signs for
all over the place is people have
chickens and they sell the eggs
yeah they collect them all and then
after a certain amount of time they eat
them if they go if they're too old but
then the fresher ones they always have
available for sale 300 eggs per year per
hen
get on it 300 eggs yeah per year per
head
if you do it right though i learned that
by watching homestead rescue
one of my favorite shows on tumblr oh
cool but so so this is an important
point though uh
you know we were talking the other day
with ryan ryan long about whether or not
this was one of the one of the tim cast
member segments
whether or not society will irreparably
change
completely when they release the
lockdown finally how
different will everything be and i was
like i think it'll be different forever
i think it's it's done it's different
new normal is here the habits you had
are gone regular people yeah absolutely
i mean i hear what you're saying but
like i'm thinking about this summer and
lockdowns being
released and all i could think about is
getting my ass back down to miami and
going to a pool party
and drinking and dancing to house music
and being around beautiful people
and that's exactly what i did i didn't
say that wouldn't happen i know but like
those are my normal habits right right
so so people who used to go to the
movies and haven't gone to the movies in
over a year might go to a movie but now
hbo max is publishing movies at the
exact same time
really really yup so when the movie
comes out now it's on streaming services
already
and guess what friends have already
formed movie night groups
where they're like hey it's friday let's
do movie night now a movie comes out
they're like oh we can go see movie
night let's do movie night let's watch
the new movie
they don't go to the theater anymore
habits are being changed completely so
here's what i say
you can't count on the government man
you can cross your fingers and hope
it'll be there for you but that's not a
guarantee
well people don't seem to understand on
the left i don't care if you call it
government
i don't care if you called a nonprofit i
don't care if you called a corporation
it is an organization that's it and
really really big ones
tend to suck comcast everybody complains
about comcast
it's a monopoly in my area they don't
answer their phones great so why do you
think the government being in trouble
something is going to change that
it's the same thing what's the
difference let me ask you a question
you know what the only real difference
in my opinion between let's say you live
in an area
where you have comcast and then you have
you know government you know provided
service of some sort
like um you can only get your
electricity or waste management is a
government program
what's the difference you pay a
subscription fee you get the service
you can complain here's the thing about
government i like better
you have rights if you have a problem
with government you can escalate it to
the authorities
these private corporations like facebook
or comcast
can do whatever what are you gonna do
i'm suing them because they won't give
me internet
you can try maybe there's a reason they
might give the internet or they'll just
be like sorry too bad go home
and you can vote the government people
out of power if they do a poor job
so there's that incentive so that's what
i'm saying is i think
a monopoly with a private monopoly is
worse
than a public monopoly but you need to
understand the difference
is very very slim if you say the
government should run
this entire system right here you're
basically saying i want a massive amount
i want comcast taking care of my health
care
i don't know about all that but i'm
actually in favor of a base level
coverage
with private hospitals and private
insurance so there's some there's still
some kind of like universal care
i i've often talked about this maybe
what we really need is that
the government acts as a referee or
provides vouchers
and that's it there's no government-run
health care there's no government-run
schools it's vouchers we all pay the
taxes
then the government says we make sure
people don't go below a certain
threshold
people who are wealthier are going to
naturally pay more because 10 percent of
a million is way more than 10 of 100.
and that means poor people will get
access by voucher to these programs but
does that mean that taxpayers have to
pay for the vouchers
yes so they're still lying in the
pockets of the exorbitant prices of
these private medical industry
but now you've got you've got
competition
you simplify the system i'm not saying
it's a perfect idea i'm saying
it might be a way this th it might be a
good solution right because we've talked
to
um who's who's the uh i'm forgetting the
guy's name
the the uh deangelis corey angela a
private a school choice guy yeah he's a
great guy but we we've also talked about
police choice
fire department choice every kind of
hospital choice i mean it makes a lot of
sense
what if you you got vouchers for
specific services and then you had to
choose who delivered those services
you'd have market competition with a
public guarantee
or or we could just stop taxing
everybody so much let you have your
money and then go make your own
right the problem with that is there are
people who like i don't like the idea
look i'm a bit left in that regard i
don't like i don't like the idea that
somebody works at mcdonald's full-time
80 hours a week maybe double time and
they can't go to the doctor
so what happens is then you have
extremely wealthy people
you want to argue flat tax or
progressive tax fine the simple
simple answer is if some dude makes a
million bucks and pays ten percent
he's paying more than someone who makes
a thousand bucks and paying ten percent
he's paying more to taxes so that will
help offset the costs only a little bit
to be completely honest
and i am a fan of the progressive tax
and i think then we have a base level so
people aren't
you know going medically bankrupt
charter schools is something i know a
lot about
i spent 10 years working in charter
schools i was a executive director of a
multiple different charter schools i was
a top regulator one of the most advanced
charter school
regulators in the country i know school
choice it is a
radical right-wing public policy
experiment
because it is it's about solving what
was a
public issue with private entities
right so charter schools are privately
owned publicly funded
and the same concept could apply to
everything like you just said police
fire
medical and what we've seen with charter
schools is that they
deliver per dollar better results
right per on a per dollar basis and what
we've seen in washington dc is that
about half of the the students in dc go
to charter schools
and what happened at the beginning is
charter schools at first outperformed
but now that it's actually half and half
they're actually performing relatively
the same
right so that means that they're
delivering the same product but they do
it with far less money yeah they do it
with
far less money they have far more
they're far more nimble
they can be shut down if they're
terrible schools and they don't meet
standards
it's a really good system and the irony
for me in working in that environment is
that
truly a radical right-wing policy
experiment implemented
in dc by georgia's senators in the 90s
right republicans completely staffed by
radical left-wing social justice
warriors that have no idea
that they're participating in the
deconstruction of the federal government
that they that they so love and hold and
hold dear but i i would love to see this
thing
see it expanded but what happens though
you know
same arguments as they make about
charter schools it's like well what
happens when
you know the rich people get all the
good cops and the poor people get all
the bad cops or you rich people get all
the good
vouchers are equal bro the vouchers are
equal
yeah so when it comes to certain
services
everybody has the same vouchers i see oh
i see you're just like i get fire
service from this company i can just
choose to go to this company or that
company but they're local that's the
problem is like if
if everybody in one area wants the good
cops and they pay their vouchers to it
then all these people
in different area also want the good
cops and pay their vouchers so then
population density will lead to better
so so then a new police department will
open up to serve that demand oh
interesting
yep it's an interesting idea uh i'd like
to see it
explored you know a little bit better i
don't know ain't gonna happen in this
administration
my friend they hate school choice more
than they hate you know
syrians and trump because they like
their heads they like the teachers vote
they want those votes yep well i'll tell
you this my friends
the excellent the perfect opportunity to
segue uh ain't gonna be nothing for the
teachers to teach
we got the story from cbs this morning
experts sound the alarm on declining
birth rates among younger generations
quote
it's a crisis before i read this i want
to tell you guys a story
uh you guys may be aware that i have a
music video that i have produced
it's called will of the people i enjoy
that song it's great it is it is a song
i made it
and i decided to just try i'm gonna run
an ad that's just a snip of the song
and then if people click it they get
brought to the full song
just to see how it performs and see if
like there's a way to actually you know
most people who who do songs and
entertainment have big marketing budgets
i don't but i was like let's buy some
google let's see what happens so i go
into google adsense
and i'm like the people who will like
this song are fans of you know rock
music
like indie rock kind of stuff probably i
think people who are into news in
politics
google gave me a demographic breakdown
of the people on youtube
who watch news this is a crazy thing 66
percent they say are men
they are uh most of them the plurality
are between the ages of 35 and 44.
and around i think it's like 65 to 70
percent
have no family that to me was crazy
those are the people of that bought your
song no no no no just the people that
are
more interested in politics yes so
google basically told me that the people
who are interested in politics on
youtube tend to be 35 to 44 with no
family makes sense if you're in
family you focus on the family less so
than on the surrounding
definitely you have far less time for
news and media consumption but but
right i have i have i have three kids
when i had two kids under two
there is a gap in my cultural
understanding of the world that started
uh around 2006
it goes to about 2009. i people ask me
when i started dating
my divorce really have you seen this
movie did you hear this song did you do
this thing like what are you talking
about i was sleeping i have no idea what
you're talking about you just have no
time to consume anything well
so this is interesting because i i saw
that and i was just surprised at
how many dudes don't have families
that i'm going to be 35 in a week i
don't got any kids so we have the story
from from cbs they say
new data is confirming a baby boom that
some doctors expected was actually a
baby bust so this is actually that
sounds like good news health departments
in more than two dozen states provided
records to cbs news showing a seven
percent drop
wait what in births in december nine
months after the first lockdowns began
researchers say it continues it
continues a much bigger plunge in
fertility in recent decades
the number of babies the average woman
in the us is expected to deliver
has dropped from nearly four in the
1950s to less than two today
the drop could present an entirely
different risk to society
than one that was first worn about
decades ago when an apocalyptic fear
gripped america in the 60s and 70s
the stakes in this battle are far
greater than any other we've ever fought
walter cronkite said in a 1970 cbs news
broadcast
the experts we interviewed told us
population was the fundamental crisis
as the world stampeded towards 10
billion people many researchers back
then
predicted that overpopulation would ruin
humanity biologist paul ehrlich
once explained the threat as the
population bomb
saying quote sometime the next 15 years
the end will come and by the end i mean
an utter breakdown of the capacity of
the planet to support humanity
today however a very different note is
struck by researchers like university of
southern california professor double
myers
who studies demographic trends quote the
trouble is we overshot
and we dropped it down too much now
myers told cbs this morning
whoa how did they drop it down that's an
interesting question
what policies did they enact
anti-natalist policies
i mean oh it's called feminism hello
about no i mean look look that's a
conspiracy theory there's no
there's there is no push there's no
there's no push between celebrities and
prominent talk shows to tell women
to abort their babies or go for your
career
you don't need that man by the time
you're 35 they'll be fine
you'll find a guy then don't worry about
it
yeah it seems like they're complaining
about it now oops meyer's set of decline
this is a crisis we need to have enough
working age people to carry the load of
these seniors
who deserve their retirement they
deserve all their entitlements
and they're gonna live out another 30
years nobody in the history of the globe
has had so many older people to deal
with
i would be interested to see what other
research that guy works on i would bet a
million dollars that either he
or his friends are also pro open borders
and interested in bringing in all kinds
of immigrant labor as well
because of the declining population yeah
or yes because of the declining
population so you're saying have babies
so that they can become slaves to the
older generation
yes exactly right yes that's no that's
exactly right
to pay for the debts that have been
promised
to the baby boomers that's exactly right
ian
i'm not into it do you have parents yeah
when they're sick will you help them
yeah so you're a slave to the older
people
you're a slave to these elderly folks no
come on all these millennials who don't
have kids
it is going to be brutal for them when
they're you know sitting there in their
70s
and there's no one take care of him
who's gonna take care of him a robot
this is the government's gonna hire
someone to do it maybe i used to call
this the crazy aunt margaret phenomenon
okay the crazy aunt margaret phenomenon
is going to be the end of feminism and
it's going to happen
in about 10 to 15 years when all these
women in their 20s and 30s who have
heard that you go
girl get your career forget about your
man all this stuff but when they get to
be 45 and 50
and they're sitting around and they're
like wait what did i do why did i do
that
we're gonna have we're gonna have a
nation of crazy aunt margarets
and then the women behind them will
observe
and be like yo i ain't gonna be like
crazy i'm margaret and you know the guys
are gonna do at 45 and 50.
they're going to be riding around their
red convertible with their high paying
job and and tons of disposable income
and they're going to be like hey
young 30 year old woman want to cruise
up to that infinity pool at the
you know the penthouse suite i got all
the money and he makes it rain and then
the younger women are going to be
like this is going to be great but like
you mentioned they're going to see the
crazy and margaret's
then they're going to see these powerful
more powerful
high status successful men and a lot of
women are going to be like
this 50 year old guy i mean you look at
movie stars
like leonardo dicaprio for instance he's
always dating these young women why
would leo date a 50 year old woman
he's going to date these young women i'm
not saying it's good or bad i'm just
saying that's what they do
the burgeoning crypto class
of men come on let's face it it's mostly
men
who dabbled in crypto in 2011 and 12
maybe bought a thousand women 80 bucks
whatever those are the guys that are
going to be running harems
in 15 years because eventually all the
women between the ages of 18 and 50 are
going to be competing for like the same
group of men
it's disaster is coming in this in this
perspective
i used to hear these numbers like
overpopulation i mean i i was
brainwashed with that growing up i
thought for sure we're overpopulated and
there's no rush to have four kids
anymore it was in the same article the
same time magazine that had the the
great
freeze the new ice age articles in it
yeah and but now i'm thinking if you
have a kid
that you can teach that might be the kid
that solves the problem
and can reorganize earth to have host 80
billion people easily did your parents
think that you would be having these
conversations on a show about like
computer code and the federal reserve if
they didn't
have a kid who was ian crossland the
conversation wouldn't happen on the show
that's a good point
if you raise your kids right they can be
the savior it's not not
incentive to have well i don't know
maybe it's an incentive to have a kid
you know sometimes uh your kids turn out
to be
i don't know crackheads and that's not
always so cool sometimes credit cards
are cool i'm trying to think back to
that statement that this guy made an
article which is very disturbing
we what was it we were too successful
we right we did it like like the efforts
yeah we went too far we went too far in
disincentivizing fertility
that's a terrifying statement super
villain what what did they do what are
the different things that they do
like feminism abortion this
desocialization of the family the
deconstruction of the family unit black
lives matter
deconstructing the family union their
family you know
etc you know it's really funny there was
a poll oh no no fault divorce there was
a poll that was posted by matthew
iglesias we brought up i think last week
i was going to mention him actually
what he he says this he's like i'm going
to break the entire discourse
and it was married men work working
married men and their opinion on who
should you know what
two parents versus one parent versus
child care and what it found was that
everybody has a bias for exactly what
they're doing so that means if a woman
is working
she thinks women should be working and
child care should take care of the kid
of course if the man is working and he's
married and the wife is watching the
kids
the man thinks the husband should work
the wife thinks the mother should raise
the kids
and that's why they chose to do it right
so what's really interesting
because whenever i have these
conversations i've seen a lot i've never
i've not heard from
from women who are mothers about you
know writing articles about why women
shouldn't be in the workplace or why
they would be happier with kids
and the reason is they're not so it's an
interesting predicament
for the women who like being
stay-at-home mothers they don't have the
career
status and power to write these articles
unless someone opens the door for them
whereas the prominent journalist class
or activist feminist class
they're the ones writing probably's
blogs so the only thing you're going to
hear is their perspective
jessica valenti yeah right right that
she was the lazy lady first
who wrote that article where she was
like cat calling is offensive and then a
year later she's like i'm sad no one cat
calls me
uh-huh so how it started how's it going
right right right here's the funny thing
this is the one subject that
really triggers people i love mentioning
this because invariably
they're going to like clip this and make
videos about it and they're going to say
installing all that
other dumb stuff i don't care dude i'm
successful i'm having a good time and we
got to talk about this
the question is according to gallup so
it was like
do you would you prefer do you think
women should be working or you know or
whatever
and 56 percent of women said they would
rather have a career
than be a stay-at-home mom but that
means 44 of women told gallup
despite everything you might hear in the
press they would rather be stay-at-home
moms
that's that's close to 50 50. and i
think those women who have careers and
all that
i'm stoked you know more power to you
that's awesome i'm glad you found
happiness
but that also means there's a lot of
women who don't want to do that and
those are the ones i think aren't being
represented properly in the media
because oh because they're not working
you know i mean they're not in these
careers in these jobs they shouldn't
pull
women they should pull their children
what do you think would you rather your
mom be at work all day or at home taking
care of you would you rather your dad be
at home you know playing ball
and going to the park with a dog or at
work if you had to choose
one of your parents has to go to work
oh my god why do you think the kid's
gonna say they're gonna pick mom why do
you think so
because mom care takes mom takes care
mom makes a peanut butter i don't know
i wanted my mom out of the house because
she was a slave driver when you were
seven
yeah she was the mean one she was yes
the lawyer my dad was
fun well she's a lawyer no she was like
the lawyer of the house
i think what you're missing is that if
mom is the caretaker
then the kid is used to mom being there
and he's feeling bad he doesn't see dad
enough so when asked he'll say i want to
see dad more
get it he sees mom all the time and you
may be right about
the mom taking care of the kid but it's
also more more proximity mom means
more stern attitude for mom as well
right look kids we're gonna take one of
your parents away which one do you want
it to be
you're right because my mom was stern
but probably only because she was around
all the time let's let's
see we're gonna go back in time we're
gonna we're gonna pull up this next
article
because i'm willing to uh trigger the
internet once again this is a story i
covered from the new york post
women are struggling to find men who
make as much money as they do
yeah and i gave a very simple hypothesis
and people did not like it because it
was an offensive hypothesis
i don't care the hypothesis goes as such
if there is a 30 year old woman who's
working a job
and she makes 75k a year and there is a
30 year old man
who works a similar job and makes 75k a
year
the woman looked at the guy and says
that's my peer that's who i want to be
with or
someone who makes more money but that
guy who's 30 making 75k a year is not
looking at a 30 year old woman
he's looking at 22 year old woman
okcupid data showed us this
that no matter what age the guy was he
would message 22 year old women
yeah guilty as charged and i got i got
it hello
that's not for me of 24 year old girls
i'm not i mean
the idea of like i guess hooking up with
a 22 year old sure i get
but and when i'm talking about a
legitimate relationship where you
actually want to have a life companion
have a family
i think it's absurd to be a 35 year old
man reaching out to 22 year olds yeah
she'd have to be really evolved
yeah that's and that's and that's why i
said 22 no 24
but even even 24 26 i've had three
significant relationships in my life and
each one of them began with a girl who
was 24.
when i was 24 when i was 30 well
i was 40. let me read this let me read
this okay the new york post writes
the country is facing a crisis of broke
dudes
according to new research from cornell
university and its left successful
single
successful ladies single and disgruntled
i wonder if they misunderstood the data
when they ask women are you finding men
your age
who have money i think the issue is it's
not so much that the dudes are broke
but that even if a guy is 30 and he's
making
25k less than the woman he's not going
to choose a woman who's 30. no the
problem is is the women are making too
much money
okay is that a problem because it's
ruined evolution
it's ruined everything that is built
into a woman's brain
a woman wants to marry a guy who's
lateral
or above and if a woman makes so much
money it
reduces her pool of available men the
fault
of their not being enough men is the
fact that women make too much money yep
boom done and the story you think you
you so
you're saying this is this is they're
getting what they've asked for i think
hahaha
live in that yeah i think by the way i'm
got a young girl at home myself
boom get rich i i don't know i don't
know if i agree with that yeah i agree
that no it changes it's all about a
dynamic
if the girls were making 35 000 a year
and that same guy was still making 70
000
a year she'd be like there's men there's
just eligible men all over the place but
now she's making the same as the guy and
she's like i don't want him but i don't
think that's absolute
i think there's if there was a guy
making 50k a year and i wouldn't make
him 150 he'd be like this is great
like we're gonna have tons of money
actually uh pew has done a number of
studies on this very thing and
women say that they want to date a man
and marry a man that makes more money
than that but everybody wants to marry
up
no i don't want to marry up okay why
would i want to marry a woman that makes
more money and works harder than i do
and spends more time i didn't say that i
didn't say that
mary up how are we calculating do you
want to marry like a woman who sleeps in
the gutter
so it doesn't have to be money it's like
if she had a herd of gold and was
willing to take care of my house and was
kind of hot and good with kids
i don't care what she does as long as
she's going to stop doing that
and she's going to start taking care of
the family wow
truth true story may i interview true
story this is a societal
difference no actually this is evolution
this is me as a man speaking to women as
women this is not
this is not crazy things go ahead i
think that jack is correct
i believe that this is known as hyper
hypergamy
hypergamy hypergamy so i have read that
men become more depressed when their
uh spouses make more money than of
course they do because that's
status this is not a case of just having
a bunch of money this is very much about
who earns the money
and for guys it is very important to
make more money than their spouse
and i don't i'm not going to say that's
materialistic i'm just going to say
that's the way that it is and this is
the data that i've read
this depresses men to make less of their
spouses this increases the risk of
divorce
yes like it's actually a problem for
guys look men
are hardwired to build create provide
and protect and if you take away
the things that we do then people are
gonna feel terrible
this this this i'm glad you brought this
up because dude i've been writing and
thinking about these issues for 10 years
man
and i just spent two hours on benjamin
boyce's channel
ranting about this stuff in my most
lucid state as a matter of fact please
check it out
i was on a roll talking about this this
is the chickens coming home to roost
in a hundred and forty eight out of 150
of the top metropolitan areas in the wa
in america entry level women make more
money than their entry-level counterpart
males right and they're unhappy about it
they've all been herded into college
saddled with debt they get good jobs
they look around
the men are just the same as them
there's nothing exciting about that
there's no hopeful future in that
there's no this guy's gonna build create
protect and provide for me
i can already build create protect and
provide for myself says the woman
and that's why tim i think you're off on
this i think that the natural age
difference builds in
this dynamic where a man and a woman
could be just as smart
just as interested in the world just as
capable but by virtue
of the age difference the man is more
established
the woman is less established you have
that status difference
the man can provide and protect the
woman can nurture and love and caretake
and people are happier that way i
strongly recommend men
don't get married until you're 35 until
your career is established you got your
money
and then definitely look for a woman
who's about 10 years younger than you
that is what was the pure research
you're talking about so i'm trying to
find it pew research uh
consistent studies that show women uh
prefer to marry a man that makes either
as much money as them or more
or more never less nevertheless
i cannot i will find it i will find it
for you i will find it
i can find though this story this study
from 2017
americans see men as the financial
providers even as women's contributions
grow
even as women are trying to make more
and more salaries men are still
viewed as the breadwinners yeah as they
should be that's the way we're designed
that's why we have testosterone that's
why we have big muscles that's why we
can smash things
that's why women are soft and sweet and
they like to cuddle things and they feed
them from their breasts
because they literally give other humans
live
that's why we're that's how we're
designed it's what our hormones do
oh oh this is crazy uh can't believe
we're getting into this on this show
jack murphy what are you doing we're
gonna get into so much trouble
let's do it from market watch may 27
2019
this one thing in your marriage
increases the risk of divorce by 33
percent
oh what is it women making more money
than men
that's the image the financial gender
balance within marriage seems to be
changing at a faster pace
they say it could be a race to finish in
more ways than one
when wives earn more than their husbands
some men
just can't handle it that's what's up
neither can the women
nobody can nobody likes only jessica
valenti out there gets off on making
more money than her husband
only jessica valenti gets off on there
thinking her husband is at home and he's
so sexy
he's so powerful and masculine he cut
the crust off the kid's sandwiches
and he wears his slippers in his health
robe all day only jessica valenti thinks
like that i've
i've seen and if they don't i'm sorry
and if the women
give lip service to this notion they're
lying well i wonder if it's about
money or because i don't know because i
don't know if it's about money like oh
it's about status and power
status and power because if a guy
becomes the president he doesn't make a
lot of money
but he's super powerful he will have and
women love that
it's about power and status and there's
no faulting women for this
women historically do not have physical
power
right the way that women have physical
powers by proxy
we are the neck that turns by making men
do things for them using cunning
guile beauty caretaking nurturing and
delivering children
men are proxy power for women this is
this is the way
you survive in the caves in the
wilderness
they can't go around beating the you
know beating up the bears and they can't
go around beating up the the hostile
groups that are going to take us over
so you got to get a man to do it for you
how do you get a man to do it for you
you look cute you look pretty you take
care of [ __ ] here's
here's what they say they say the risk
of divorce is nearly 33
higher when a husband isn't working
full-time according to money work and
marital stability
assessing change in the gender
determinants of divorce a 2016 study
of more than 6 300 couples by alexandra
killerwald
professor of sociology at harvard
university quote
for marriages formed after 1975 husbands
lack of full-time employment is
associated with higher risk of divorce
expectations of wives homemaking may
have eroded but the husband breadwinner
norm persists
the apparent disconnect may be due to
peer pressure or attitudes passed down
from parents
another theory through evolution a
persistent glass ceiling for women at
work
may encourage men to believe they should
also be the highest earners at home
persistently one thing they never talk
about though is
it there's always an excuse but it's
always the man's fault
of course it is because everything is a
man's fault period this sounds like it's
like a
lack of purpose issue with if someone
doesn't have a full-time job maybe
they're
missing purpose in their life and they
become much less attractive that is a
separate issue but yes you're exactly
right people don't have a mission or a
purpose or an expression of values
that's unrelated
to their source of income and people
have terrible horrible lives when their
values and their mission and their
purpose
aren't aligned with the things that they
have to do to earn money i would even
like to see
independently wealthy people that
inherit a bunch of money that don't have
jobs
and see their rates of success in
marriage because i think that would be
low also
if you don't have something that you
love outside yourself
those two things aren't necessarily the
case you can be born with a lot of money
and have passions you know
building no meat or but my point is or
whatever it's not that women or men
seek money in their partner it's that
they seek drive ambition status and
power or potential for it no what they
seek is
differential power that's what they both
parties seek
what do you mean by that because you can
be a broke-ass dude
and find a woman that looks up to you
who because she's broker
right this is relative power yes it's
about relative power
it's about relative power and relative
status a woman that doesn't have a job
doesn't care doesn't have any education
latches on to a guy that's got a minimum
wage job
and and has a room in a house somewhere
well she's moving up in the world
right it's all about relative power and
that's why the more okay look
more women graduate high school more
women apply
to go to college more women graduate
college
more women get hired out of school for
jobs women make more money than men
coming out of school
women live longer are healthier have
less alcoholism drug use
suicide and at the end of the day they
control more wealth when they die
yep okay interesting and all these
things are pushing
and they're happening they're happening
and at the same time women's
satisfaction in life has gone down
marriage rates have gone down divorce
rates are
you know going down but less so than
with the marriage rate so more people
are getting divorced
fertility is down childbirth is down
happiness is down
why it's not because we live in a world
that's like
horrible terrible place we live in a
world of abundance we have everything
that we want
this is the greatest time to be alive i
got i come on finish this thought
it's the greatest time to be alive but
these women are miserable
because they make more money they're
more educated they have more power than
they really want
and the pool of men available to them
diminishes with
each step that they take up the ladder
it is a self-defeating cycle
that we can all observe on the outside
and man i'm so glad we're talking about
this problem
i've been writing about this for 10
years i'll make it simple it doesn't
matter if it's the men's fault
they want to write these studies and
they say men can't handle that women
make more money than them
it's like okay well that just means that
women still can't date the men
you can blame the men for it but if a
woman wants to date a man
and she wants to find a good man and men
don't like this because you think they
can't handle it well then make a choice
do you want to date them or do you want
to adhere to what the man wants so it's
like
when you're in a relationship you don't
just dictate the relate you know you
don't say
you're dating me now that's it no every
relationship is are we providing
something to each other in some capacity
that makes us feel fulfilled that
relationship will work
if this story from the new york post
says that
you know these these women can't find
men who may make as much money as them
and then this other study says men can't
handle it well then it sounds like
it sounds like both parties are
dissatisfied but by by all means
say the men are losers who can't handle
it okay that still means the one doesn't
get a date
yeah so there we go it's an impasse
right well it's every
the system is flawed we do we have just
continued we've just decided to just
and this is feminism this is so critical
race theory
this is sjw this is the whole thing
about the radical left
we have obliterated uh the differences
between men and women
in our minds and in our discourse but
you can't erase the biological
evolutionary differences that are built
into us
millions of players but social
influences as well that's a big time
because when you
when you remove the incentive to do
better to people then they
strive less to do better i've done my
best work for the most part when i
didn't have enough
and i needed to get more i needed i was
seeking that power once i get the power
i find that there's this tendency to sit
on my laurels to rest back and be like
now
you gotta work on that bro right so i
have to create like this outside
invisible enemy that i need to overcome
basically
i love peterson's work he talks a lot
about this stuff i keep thinking about
him when we're talking about this
um so you know this whole social
structure where you have enough you have
everything government's going to take
care of you i think it's killing
incentives
i also think that you insult and demean
the maturity
and capabilities of 24 5 year old women
yeah absolutely there's no reason in the
world a mature established 35 year old
man
cannot have a healthy productive
fruitful relationship
with a woman 10 years younger than him i
didn't say that i just think
you just said they were immature and
they shouldn't be matched up 22
okay 22 23 24. look they're women mature
way more college women mature way more
quickly than men dude
way more quickly at the age at age 15
women they're basically women already
right and it's like men take men hit
their prime
in their 30s 35 why wouldn't a man in
his prime
latch on to a woman in her prime why not
that seems the most logical thing
possible that's what's happened for
millennia from millennia older men would
marry like 15
year olds and the society creeping the
societal
[ __ ] in this society around dating a
younger woman
is just jealousy it's jealousy
because as you said every man in the
world wants to date a 22 year old woman
according to okay cupid data according
to okay cupid i don't know
your own two eyes all of history every
piece of letter i'm excited
every book you've ever seen because it's
not your opinion okcupid actually
trapped
all the messages and they found no
matter how old a guy was from
even younger guys why do you think that
is always mentioning 22 year olds why do
you think that is for
i think by evolution like biological
reasons oh right exactly right and
and what okcupid found was that very
disgustingly in my opinion men are
actually attracted to women much
much much younger than that but would
not want to have a family with someone
younger than that
so men choose 22 as the equilibrium
between mental and physical maturity
why is that disgusting there's nothing
there's nothing
wrong with little kids of course dude
well there's
that's hyperbolic on my part right but
there's literally nothing wrong with
seeing
a woman of fertile age and thinking she
is an attractive sexual partner
but like acting on that with an 18 year
old woman is a completely different
story
but there's nothing wrong with seeing an
eighteen-year-old girl woman
and being like oh she's attractive of
course she is she's in the prime
of her beauty 18. okay cupid data said
men want women younger than that
okay mom and that i find creepy yeah it
is because society society has rules
like
it is creepy today but guess what it
wasn't creepy until just recently
i don't know all of humanity all of
history all of time i still think it was
creepy
i think i think i think a lot of past
cultures did a lot of really creepy
growth stuff
yeah well of course of course and of
course i'm not advocating
for guys in their thirties anyone under
22. but i think it's perfectly
reasonable to have a relationship with a
woman who's in her early 20s
if you're in your 30s well that's
absolutely reasonable let's go to super
chats
and uh here we go we're going to have uh
we'll do a bonus segment yeah you're on
for that right yeah man i'm on for it it
won't be it won't be too long though but
uh
i'm up for it i got to go plus i got a
guy home i got a 14 year old woman
a woman 14 years younger than me at home
waiting for me there you go
[Laughter]
smash the like button my friends and
check out timcast.com because i think
it's going to get spicy jack's going to
go off on this this huge rant about
manliness and stuff so we'll carry that
conversation over but uh subscribe hit
the notification bell
share this podcast if you really do like
it because that's what helps podcasts
grow
i keep hearing it from all these you
know bigwigs they're like if you want to
make your podcast big
people who listen to podcasts are the
ones who tell people to listen to
podcasts that's what you have to do and
i'm like okay
i guess that's the secret so if you want
to help out that's true we got here
lmv188 says love the show do you think
the dems will evoke the 25th on biden
or is it more likely he will die in
office
more likely they evoke the 25th you
think so i don't know if that they will
but i think it's more likely than him
dying yeah maybe
no he's going to i think i think uh life
expectancies tell us
that buying is going to die pretty soon
although if you saw life thinking about
these two years past it this study of
something all this life extension
technology out of harvard that they're
working on nicotinamide mononucleotide
resveratrol
um things like that yeah aubry de grey
uh he said this like a decade ago that
10 years ago he said someone who's 45
today will live to be a thousand and it
it was also it was tying into what we
were just talking about you jackson i
would be a thousand
i don't know you were you how old were
you 10 years ago oh 35 so i'm even
i'm golden and what he said what he said
was he's one of the he's like one of the
the most prominent senescence
researchers
he said it's not because we're going to
invent immortality it's because the
things that kill people are being cured
people don't die of old age they die of
renal failure or heart failure or you
know
something like that but as as people are
aging right now
medical technology is advancing faster
than
than people are dying so that's what he
said 10 years ago we'll see if he's
tying into what we're conversation we're
just having about age like
dating people and fertility rates
because i think women will stay fertile
much
longer in this society and that 60 70 80
year old women will be able to have
babies
i don't know about that yeah it looks
like it that's what the data is tending
to oh wow
all right we got it we got to go in here
josh says love the show tim been
listening uh chief about a year
are you still interested uh are you
still taking guest recommendations no we
never take
recommendations mind you would love to
see nicole arbour on your show smart
lady and kick ass comedy bless
uh that's actually gonna be happening
yes it is at some point
so she i think she's great i think she's
hilarious she's great
yeah let me know if you need to sit in
on that
dwight try uh cuetra
is having issues logging in if you're
having issues just email members at
timcast.com yes
and we will help you get into the site
and for any
other email there's info at timcast.com
so yes
brendan says get tom not on the podcast
my friends
there are like 50 people that we've
reached out to that are like yes we want
to come on the show
and they're in canada you can't do it
or they're concerned about the copen
justin well i mean that's mostly lefties
but justin trudeau in canada he's like
he's sitting there at the border just
like you know looking around waiting for
any of these
any of these people to try and cross
over to the states and then he runs over
and he grabs them and then they lock him
in a coco
he wants to come on the show too we've
been trying to get him on the show i
would love that you're doing the show i
mean yeah but that was never going to
happen i want to see his sucks
true dough let's have some legitimate
questions on it you in a two-hour sit
down where you can't leave like
why not talk it would be like good man
for the first time in the guy's life you
have to tell the truth
never do that people don't want to sit
in the hot seat he's an entertainer you
might
oh that's interesting beautiful bliss
says what's the counter argument for
democrats for declining birth rates
i wonder hi lydia i don't know
probably it's a good thing all right
let's jump down what is this randomatic
says trump to biden voters are you sorry
yet
dell men says hello beanie compound
great news minnesota governor uh
government has rescinded their decision
to spend taxpayer money on influencers
for the derrick chovin trial what
how nice of that because minnesota
doesn't trust the government to do the
right thing what does that mean
influencers
yeah they were going to pay influencers
to like influence people about the
showman trial whoa
whoa yeah you didn't i didn't know that
that's a story
yeah that's creepy what i'm shocked you
did not see that story
northern blue collar says hello from
maine keep up the great reporting i love
listening to y'all while i work
and we love getting your money in super
chats it makes it all worth it
thanks man we gotta you here we got it
we got a new show coming
i heard colts crime mystery paranormal i
heard
it's going to be more like a legit show
like we'll do like 13 episodes we'll
record them on the weekends and then
we'll just like release them out so
it'll be not the same it's like a
topical
news show it's ever green evergreen
entertainment
with guests from cults and like alien
civilizations
redux yeah i'm hoping we can get like a
legit murderer
like like from prison no joke like yeah
that'd be awesome i will not be here
though not
in the well they're
but uh the paranormal stuff i'm really
excited for because i want to do this
for a while yeah dude i want to get like
a legit researcher who's like you know i
work at this university we track the
stuff
here's what we think and then it's going
to be great we're going to do sound
effects and creeps dude the cult stuff
is fascinating
just the the mind of a cult member or
reformed cult member i love that stuff
especially with the age of cult
personnel there's a personality there's
also some
people who deny their they're in a cult
there's like
reports of like here's a cult and the
people like it's not a cult and
so i'm really should have those
conversations i mean who gets to decide
if it's a cult or not
i don't know the size of the cult i
don't know man
i mean i've been watching watching so i
watched the nexium
series and i watched wild wild country
what's wild wild country about oh that's
about that indian guy
and and his right-hand woman who took
over a town in
oregon or washington oh that's right
that's right that's right yeah yeah
and you know it's like what's a cult
could they leave
the nexium people couldn't leave they
couldn't leave no they couldn't leave
because they gave up collateral on
themselves like
pictures of them and cheating on their
husband or whatever plus they got
branded
and all these things and then when they
tried to leave they wouldn't let them
but the
wild wild country people they said it
was a cult but like no one was forcing
them to be but did you did you see what
nikki klein said
i don't know who that is she was
somewhat she was one of the members of
the d.o.s
they called the deal oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's denied all of that she
said it's not true she said the media
was lying about everything
sensational had lines i wouldn't be
surprised i wouldn't be surprised i mean
i watched the nexium thing and it was
about three episodes i'm not saying
she's right i was about threes
three episodes in and i was like i
haven't seen anything
i haven't seen anything wrong here yet
with nexium yeah oh really
yeah at the first the first text well
that's how it was portrayed
well so i'm not i'm not i'm saying the
media has reported it as a cult
nikki klein who i actually have met
because i was at i think i met her
i'm not sure i met some people from
nixon at cpac
and then i i think they introduced me to
nikki klein
and this was back when i was doing a
really old podcast and we were gonna do
a podcast we ended up not actually using
it
because that's when the news was
breaking about the cult and all that
stuff so i wonder if we still have some
of that stuff
but i'd be interested in talking to her
like you say it's not a cult
this here's all the stuff saying it was
and don't you think people who are in
cults would deny
being in a cult i mean what is a cult
though a cult is
is somebody looking in from the outside
and not being able to understand the
motivations of the people staying on the
inside
people people call things a cult because
they don't understand christianity is a
cult
people have said it that's why i said
the size well let's read some more super
chats though
northern blue collar says i love the
debates you and ian have
oh me too and then brian says free the
code is the stupidest thing ever and
only a vile socialist who doesn't code
would say something like that
something something that ignorant code
is work i would say
to explain a little bit of that i don't
want to free all the software code in
the world i think that's
it would be bad um but when a when a
social network which is a unique
business that we're now dealing with in
life
reaches 100 million users a month or
something that it becomes part of the
commons
and then i believe we have the right as
sovereign citizens to take control of
that
commons and protect the commons and do
that by freeing that software code
i got to read this one bobby bob says i
want jack to hold me lovingly
rub his beard on my face and gently
whisper freedom in my ear
pasta must be involved his choice
freedom
and freedom infusilly okay okay sounds
good
all right the civic nationalist says the
pilgrims fled because great britain
wasn't religious enough
the u.s was made by terrorists and you
still paid for the goods destroyed
the u.s is a failed state there were
more loyalists in the colonies
stop talking about this you are not able
to god save the queen it's actually
so it's it's not sure that there were
more loyalists that's just british
propaganda from british nationalists
but it is true that it was only a
plurality
that wanted independence yeah it's true
so there was a vote
like the sentiment among the colony was
like you know 38
says independence and then like you know
28
said loyalty and the rest said shut up
and leave me alone
and it was to shut up and leave me alone
people that basically
you know and if any one of them were
just like okay we'll stay with great
britain then we would have not have had
independence
it wouldn't happened but they uh
essentially abstained so
all right would we have the federal
reserve if it would have stayed with
great britain
yeah but it would have been called the
bank of england
[Laughter]
all right let's see snap crackle pop
says tim remember the reason the dollar
menu is now called the value menu is
because of inflation
and democrat politics sparky the pyro
says boy am i glad
i'm glad i know how to grow food and
hunt with these food prices
need me some chickens and a couple of
goats yes
well we were considering goats but they
screamed yeah they bleep
they just yell and so nobody wants to
wake up to screaming goats we
we're going to get chickens i want to
get roosters
the roosters screamed too like you know
what you know i realized what are you
gonna do with the rooster
bro the roasters protect the chickens oh
you let them walk around
you put up you gotta have a chicken coop
around here i have a flavor
i bought a big massive chicken you got
predators bro what are you gonna do with
the rooster
you need hens and broilers what i have
we're gonna so we bought a
bunch of chicken coops yeah we're gonna
get a bunch of chickens do it and i was
considering getting a bunch of roosters
a bunch meaning like a couple because
you need a lot of chickens the problem
is they scream
and we record in a studio here that's
true well you know what
in the morning it'd be like mid midway
through
every single one of my podcasts which i
do at 12 o'clock
i'm doing one tomorrow and thursday uh
the mailman comes
and rosie my dog barks so around
in every podcast rosie barks rosie barks
and everybody laughs
and then we just move on it's just part
of the show yeah but roosters yell
randomly
yeah they do and you're saying we don't
need them well if we take care of the
chickens
if we want if we want babies i guess but
uh
yeah you know there's a uh at the
well there's one place i go to where
they have three just they're big
they're big roosters and they keep
predators away
yeah there's the and so i was asking one
of the guys there i was like the rooster
is enough
like we have dogs too and i was like
there it is
roosters will run after predators and
they also tell the chickens to go home
when it gets dark
so but we'll probably just set up a big
enclosure where it's like
we're gonna secure it so that predators
can't get in or anything
but if we have chickens we can actually
keep it in a secure area the problem was
we have a really great place to put it
where it's surrounded on on you know
three sides so there's no predator
coming in only from one direction
and then we can actually secure that
very straight very well and then have
the coupe inside it secure it as well
the problem is it's close to the house
so if we get roosters
you're going to hear the roosters
everywhere so it's like maybe we'll just
get chickens
we can always start with chickens i was
thinking homesteading man you've got
eggs
goats and herbs that's easy right it's
like every morning you can wake up to
like a goat cheese
omelette with like herbs you used to
milk them that doesn't sound like
that's not rough in it by any means that
sounds amazing that's great
i gotta go for a goat right now we got
to read some more we added some more so
image jpeg says the only thing that can
stop crypto is if governments go back to
sound money won't happen
however in my opinion btc is overvalued
check out coin fair value
satoshi's white paper was for ecash not
store of value
that's fine but it doesn't matter i hear
a lot of people saying this they're like
oh the original vision so they have
bitcoin cash
where it's like it's it's faster
transactions and it's worth a lot less
but you can trade it really quickly
they all exist all these little cryptos
exist where you can instantly trade
value
the minds token for instance has value
to some people and in the library token
or whatever
bitcoin has become a store of value
that's that's it you cannot like it but
that's how it
that's what it's become i think the
problem is
maybe satoshi didn't realize governments
were going to be dumping massive amounts
of money into this
and that means the demand is massive and
the supply
is literally diminishing you know it's
so funny that the government says
no one is allowed to mint a currency but
us ah
what couldn't stop it so they're just
letting it happen you can't stop and it
happened why aren't they
aren't they the ones buying everything
and then they're buying it maybe maybe
m1 all that just they're just buying up
bitcoins
so maybe the whole you can't print your
own money supply thing should be tossed
out the window i mean it's being
ignored so let's just say you can print
your own money supply
and change the constitution and let
people make their own cryptos
all right we gotta we gotta read some
more we got a good one here joey says i
remember when the whopper was
one dollar how much is it nowadays
like six bucks it was a guess
14 maybe maybe 16 years ago
there was a burger king in my
neighborhood and their sign
was hard printed yeah 99 whopper yeah
yeah hard hard like it wasn't something
they changed it was permanently there
and then i remember when they finally
broke it
yeah because it was it was not a banner
it was like the sign it's upside burking
in under it it's like the 99 cent
whopper
and then eventually when they're like
that's too expensive it just it broke
the sign
i lived i lived in the south side man it
wasn't like a you know good place they
were just like get the hammer
or someone broke it i don't know maybe
someone shot it last time i bought a
whopper is 229 maybe
they cost 419 now yeah wow 419.
matthew stockhausen says technically any
state can leave the union if they want
to fight the usa for freedom
that's a good point yeah read texas i
don't think it's a good idea
whenever they talk about secession like
you'll have a blockade in the gulf of
mexico all that oil
the fed is not going to give up that oil
you know federal government i should say
do you think there's the stomach by the
other 49 states
in the union to actually say oh texas
seceded
other 49 states are going to be like
invade them nope
no that era has changed man look at
scotland voting for independence
like scotland was essentially conquered
wasn't it well i don't know anything
about great britain i'm going to trigger
all the british people they're going to
be like no you know nothing and it's
like okay fine whatever
but we're at a point now where it's like
i guess catalonia
they keep trying to leave spain and then
the federal police come in and just
start beating people mercilessly so
there you go
i don't think people would go for that
yeah i know it's like the federal cops
are not the state or the people they're
not the people there's like a that's
what we're talking about like the nsa
and the homeland security and the fbi
like that's a lot of militant force that
the federal government has
we'll keep going through the super chats
uh c hennessey says best analogy for
america is a skyscraper
and each floor is a year of america the
founding fathers laid the foundation
and now the people on the 244th floor
wants to take out the foundation that
the whole 244th floor sits on
indeed interesting katie says
have to sit with an assignment for six
hours forced to write about black lives
matter and white supremacy
i have to pass it to graduate this
summer so i would like to know if i
only pass if i only pass if i go full
leftist sounds like it
wow look it's a time it's a time honored
tradition to
write whatever it is that you think your
professors want you to write in order to
get an
a and not believe a single word of it so
just do what everybody's always done in
college
or write what you truly believe and
frame it and throw the finger up
here's a good super chat from welder he
says tim no income tax no progressive
tax only a sales tax
the more you buy the more you pay the
rich that buy more will pay more and the
poor can save
that's an interesting idea i've heard
that before maybe you just do a really
high sales tax like relative to where it
is now like increase it
so that it offsets everything and then
whoever consumes the most that would
actually be a good green solution right
to all of these lefties who want you
know to fight climate change and stuff
because then you're basically saying by
all means buy whatever you want but
there's a lot of taxes attached to those
purchases
value-add taxes are regressive yeah
they're regressive if it's in some
places they have a 19 vat
it means you go if you if you spend one
dollars 19 cents it's a lot
but but if there's no income tax no i
understand but
if when you when that is just i'm pretty
sure that
is just known to be regressive because
it does not
increase percentage-wise uh for rich
people
right the poor people are paying the
same taxes so it's regressive but if
rich people are buying tons of stuff
like crazy yeah then they end up
spending way more in taxes
yeah i mean sitting in luke's seat right
now i can think to myself hey
i prefer when the government doesn't tax
anything for anybody the value-added tax
is interesting that's what
andrew yang wanted to use to pay for
basic income
and a friend of mine aaron was
explaining that
the supply chain would be taxed at every
point so
the people that grow the rice sell it to
the the manufacturers there's a tax on
it
and then that's the value that's the
value out of tax on that then the
manufacturer sells it to the store
there's a value-added tax on that the
store brings it to the person there's
value-added tax put on that and then
what it would do is cause
a markup in the price of the product to
cover
the all of the embedded taxes along the
chain
right all right this one's for you jack
benjamin haver says i am 38 and have no
family
both of my own and older uh both of my
own and older than me
it's been a hard road also i'm a huge
fan of y'all's work much respect
no family yes good super chat thank you
thanks for watching the show appreciate
it william kelly says hey tim how dare
you
for being exactly 10 days older than me
and share my twin's name
then again my twin is my political polar
opposite oh really
like a left like you have a twin and
then one's left wing and one's right
winger interesting
it's a combination uh my birthday is
march 9th
it is coming up very soon happy birthday
about six days thirty-five and i will be
35
years old a big year ryan law says
wondering if you guys heard about how
the national guard troops at the capitol
are being treated
they're getting sick from raw and molded
food i dm the story to your instagram
tim
uh i did and metal shavings yeah metal
shape i saw that is that
that's legit it's probably from the cans
when they're like making potatoes
and they're scraping it oh no yup yup
yup and
now when i heard about the raw beef i
was kind of like
is that so bad i like my steaks rare i
guess if you're getting garbage freezer
food though and you don't know where
it's been
you probably wanted to because it's
probably not steak tartar the raw
chicken though
oh yeah that's like dude they're
mistreating these guys it is such
they feed them raw chicken that's why
i'm saying it feels like everything's
falling apart
when our national guard are supposed to
be defending the capital and we can't
even feed them you got to defend the
national guard before you use them to
defend the capital
you have you ever think about how these
massive armies like the crusades
they had to have food man armies march
on their bellies yup
they have like huge baggage trends
one of the wealthiest countries if not
the wealthiest country on the planet
right now can't
get food to our own national guard
in the capital no it's not in the
capital it's not that they can't
it's that they won't that's the case
still decay's okay
but all right but there's a big
difference between somehow we just can't
and we have all the resource resources
in the world
money printer go bur we can't we won't
why do you think what do you mean they
won't like what are they not doing what
is a limiting factor from them buying a
high quality food
choice choice it's a choice yeah same
with hospitals
i feel like the hospital should have
healthy food institutionalized food
delivery is tough
um but schools hospitals and the
military are suffering from
a lack of nutrition that's a big problem
and that's another
part of why government is is kind of
kind of an issue
kind of i'm just saying if we can't tell
you about that that's a bit of an issue
i could go into it all right we got to
read this one messa uh
mesa's own one message one i don't know
why people are so mad at cuomo for the
nursing home stuff he was just trying
out a bold new strategy to solving the
looming social society crisis
yeah too many old people then we won't
have to uh bring in more immigrants and
we can solve the fertility issue
the entitlement issue the peer th the
great pyramid scheme that is america
by the way yeah we can solve that
problem just by killing all the old
people
this is a joke obviously youtube over
overlords
this is important oh boy alex ryan says
tim get a donkey
a donkey will act as a guard for your
chickens they're brutal to predators
it's an
awesome sight to watch a donkey stomp a
coyote
i've heard that wow they'll just like
fun just
like get away from the chickens the
chickens are my friends wow donkeys i
hear donkeys are awesome they're great
way better than horses were they bray is
that the noise they er
yep that's how
goat man jack says don't you judge my
people's music
yeah so when i when i lived in miami
with adam
the neighbors had a goat and just a goat
would yell
all the time so it's not enjoyable when
you're trying to sleep and it's like 7
a.m and you're out
yeah bleat on yeah lead on bleeder
notoriously wise says tim i've been in
the beanie cult for about nine months
now but i never got my new follower
beanie who do i contact do we don't have
beanies do we
we we actually reached out to a bunch of
companies to make these kinds of beanies
and it's hard because it's dual colors
so you need like a good factory but
everything was shut down for coved
hey as a as an aside i wore the i'm a
gorilla t-shirt yesterday and it is
really comfortable it's comfortable
good shirts huh that's that's weird
spring doesn't do beanies maybe we
should maybe they could they do but
they're always these just like
acrylic embroidered not all uh we have
liminal order beanies as well
uh through are they are like no they're
really nice through printful
through printful and shopify and it's
totally sold out totally sold out can't
get any more wow
oh wow yeah see there you go
jay rich says one of the biggest
contributors to the declining birth rate
is third wave feminism
and the rise of gynocentric society
centered around
b rating masculinity and brow-beating
men for being men
make females women again yep so third
wave feminism is this is the distortion
of feminism
over the last 20 or 30 years yeah it's
the step beyond like maybe they should
vote
yeah maybe we're all equal yeah it's the
step beyond that it's a step beyond that
it is it really is
yeah mark roberts says tim i truly
appreciate your cast and everyone's
viewpoint
thanks so much for your work best to
everyone hey appreciate it that was a
great one dude thank you
christopher blummer says for jack murphy
yes sir do you think keanu reeves is a
mgtow
make tough it means men going their own
way i couldn't tell you i have no idea
is he single
have you seen i thought he was married
to some older lady yeah no he's single
and he was married he was it wasn't a 55
year old woman yeah he was
a silver hair yeah he was yeah really
really all the photos of him with women
his hands he's doing hover hands
yeah yeah he's legit that one i i think
was not i think that was legit like
the me too thing was at its peak and
then all these photos started emerging
of kendall reeves and his hands were
never on women
and i'm like dude he's playing it safe
i'm pretty sure he's dating an older
woman who doesn't dye her hair and there
was like a whole thing about it i
remember even tweeting about it now that
i think about it
i have no idea if he's a mgtow i don't i
don't recommend that by the way
don't go your own way man become a
better man all right find a woman have a
family
be a rebel ai or al whichever one says
tim you seriously need to do a
discussion on the mouse utopia
experiment
it nearly perfectly mirrors the modern
day problems
also promiscuity is killing the
long-term dating world look up
retroactive jealousy
oh interesting yeah i think i've heard
about that the mouse utopia experiment i
think i've read about that was that
where like
they gave the mice everything they could
ever want
and then they ended up just getting like
fat lazy and then not reproducing and
then just slowly dying off oh
yeah something like that look the
fertility issue is something that we
should have actually a deeper discussion
on because it's not just the united
states
it's europe as well it's everywhere with
advanced technology
i think that this is the precursor to
some transhumanist kind of thing
happening and
a society like as a as an entity in a
whole we might have some
expectation of a huge change genderless
evolution and babies born in test tubes
kathy's uh smacking you down smack
smackdown from kathy
kathy what's up kathy mack says what is
wrong with you people what a sad
generation
you pick a spouse by finding someone
that enjoys the same things i made twice
as much as my husband
but it was all our money also we have
been married 41 years
good for you yeah i like that good for
you congratulations
i agree with that man i don't think that
personally i i might be different than
most but i don't think the money
i guess i understand we're saying about
power and drive because i am attracted
to women that are driven
to create and do something yeah look
getting married
because you like this person this is a
new thing
this is a new thing this has never been
the case romantic love is a new thing
it's a modern creation
it is yeah it is it's incredible yeah it
used to be like arranged marriages and
dowries and all that stuff and it was
like
that the dad would basically sell off
the daughter in
a manner of speaking i have the dowry
and then there would be a good man and
then
that i would like i approve of this man
the opposite of selling
yeah right right the dad's giving the
dowry oh right
right all right yeah it's weird it's
weird like the eligible men
were yeah they received you get a woman
and a bunch of people yeah right right
right pretty good deal that's the called
the patriarchy
yeah there you go patreon yeah it works
great i i called and a stack of cash
so i had a friend and i i jokingly
called her a spinster and she got really
offended
and i was like why are you offended by
that and she was like don't call me a
spinster
and i was like i thought that was like a
like a funny thing nowadays
it's like it used to be an insult back
then you know what i mean what is it
someone that spins
so it was typically the women who were
spinning was it cotton
cotton that's not hay it was because
they weren't they were working they were
working women so they were called
spinsters and then
spinster became a term for a woman who
wasn't married and didn't have kids
because she was working right because
she had to spend the rest of her life
spinning up yarn yeah jeez we live in
them yeah but like nowadays
it's like tongue-in-cheek it was like i
think spinster
insinuates that a woman is barren yeah
really and a woman that doesn't have any
bearing
societally like this with my husband no
family know anything
i'm sorry why would you be mad at me for
that if you're like a high-powered
working woman because it triggers the
evolutionary brain that can't be turned
off
it's also how like the left tries
calling men in cells
because they're trying to go after
masculinity
yes it's a weird thing to do because
it's like
it's just like it's like i don't know
it's it's it's antithetical to what they
claim to support
of course it's dude i just had a huge
long thread this weekend on progressive
alpha males and how they don't exist by
definition right
we should we should say that for the for
after yeah we'll we'll go we'll go ham
on all that stuff dude that was a good
one
that was huge travis sharon says donkeys
scream i stayed at lake pleasant arizona
last weekend loud
okay you convinced me experimental says
don't buy a donkey the donkey will mind
control you then it will make you join
and completely support the democratic
establishment oh my gosh he's right
get an elephant there you go perfect
then the tiger yes i like it we'll call
it never never land no gosh let's not
kn clark says washington state is sales
tax only no income tax
bad idea poor can't save they actually
pay a higher percent in taxes just
buying necessities that's a good point
that's a good point we're aggressive
steve selena says tim my birthday is
march 9th gonna be 27. love your show
bro and i'm glad i share my b day with
such an awesome guy i love you guys
you know what's crazy day is uh adam's
birthday is right before mine as well
yeah what is it march seven yeah
and then uh crazy bro it's a good year
for birthday there's another there's
another
person who has a birthday two days after
mine
but i don't know if their birthday is is
public so i won't say but we're gonna
have a big party it's gonna be great oh
nice
maybe we'll do a show or something
really big party i you know my
invitation must have got lost in the
mail yeah it sure did
oh yeah yeah yeah definitely where's the
e-lights
inkspot says get out of the cities this
is all building to the next world war
the next
the new world order and the culling
through war famine and unspeakable
strife
well i don't know i don't know about all
that but i do think you will be ever so
happy
with chickens dude at all i just gotta
tell you man i had chickens in miami
they're hilarious they're like dinosaurs
they're just funny it's like
watching them do their thing they're
just hilarious they're so dumb if you
fell in a pit of chickens and passed out
where they eat you yeah
probably yeah okay they eat they eat
your animals like they're
they're carnivores yeah big spice when
you ask someone what are chickens eat
what do you think they're going to tell
you
they eat grubs and they eat
grass they eat grass oh man they
mutilated my lawn
yeah they tear up your life so you move
them around yeah well you just you give
them a big enough space to where they
don't destroy the whole lawn
but they were like crazy they're
annihilating it yeah but the problem was
the rooster we had was
really dumb and kind of a loser and he
would run away and not protect the
chickens so we were like what are you
doing
so we called him um we called him norind
he does there do you know nor in the
weary yes that's the magic the gathering
creature there's a there's a there's a
card in magic gathering called nor in
the weary it's terrible
no it's amazing it's a brilliant card
but he's the character is like mortified
and always running away that's the point
well see even a male chicken that can't
provide or protect
is worthless good point nailed it
evolution has spoken i would have
chopped this you know what he would do
it was really funny
he would jump over the fence because he
kept oh this is hilarious
we didn't have enough chickens and we
didn't realize this and he kept banging
them like crazy
and then he would jump over the fence
people don't realize how high they can
they can all
they can like basically they can do big
jumps yeah they can almost fly
they can't really fly they can jump
really high and then they like come down
so he jumped over like i think it was
like a six and a half seven foot fence
and we can't get over it to get him and
he jumps over
because he can hear all the all the hot
chicken ladies you know so he's like i'm
a rooster and i can hear these
i can hear these chickens and he jumps
over here's a problem
those chickens had roosters oh and the
roots over there were
massive big old roosters and they
basically said gtfo
but he wasn't smart enough to jump back
over so he would just get stuck in the
corner
and then we have to go to the neighbors
and they would come over and pick him up
and throw him over and i'll tell you the
funniest thing ever
he got trapped over there for like a day
or two and then the
the chickens we had were just like doing
their chicken business and so we're
trying to figure like what happened to
him he's gone
and that was like the first time we
realized he was jumping the fence and so
we asked the neighbors the neighbors
were like oh is that your rooster we
were wondering like where this thing
came from
so they throw they they they don't throw
more than they put up they drop them
over the fence and then he
as soon as he lands we're standing there
and we watch him just run full speed
and then jump on the chicken and start
banging the chickens we all just bust
out laughs what is it like when chickens
bang they're like birds he jumps on
their back and then digs his feet and
rips their back open
do they scream in pain no that's how
cats do it it's real quick
you'll see that woman cat just tears
tearing it up screaming have you ever
seen that
all right all right let's uh we'll do uh
we'll do one more here
uh sam bada says tim get rolo tomasi on
the show he wants
jack's just paraphrasing rollo's book
the rational mail rolo has been the
authority on
sexual dynamics for 20 years now
whatever so we should have you whatever
i've known rolo for 10 years i've known
rolo before he ever wrote a book i know
rolo before you're saying he should come
on with you
rolo and his whole crew blocked me a
year ago
that would be good mad jelly that jelly
so wow oh we're good we're reigniting
the beef what is it
what is his premise rollo and i came up
in the same place rolo they call him the
king in the manosphere and i'll give him
credit he did
write a lot of things down but man rollo
and me
and a handful of other guys mike who was
even in here the other day
we all co-evolved that whole scene we
co-evolved the whole story
i've been talking about this stuff for
10 years same as rolo
that would be really funny that would be
really funny hey baby we should have
that chat
all right ladies and gentlemen we are
going to talk about the progressive
alpha i suppose
at timecast.com so that'll be up in
about an hour or so so go to timcast.com
become a member
and uh we'll have that up soon don't
forget to like share subscribe
smash that like button if you really
like this podcast leave us a good review
on itunes or spotify if you haven't
check it out
because then it like you know boosts you
up in the ratings and then you share it
and then people see it and then it just
says you know it's great it's great
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comcast
and youtube.comcastnews this show is
live monday the friday at 8pm so we'll
be back of course tomorrow
jack you want to shout out some stuff
yes uh please follow me a subscribe on
my youtube channel we're approaching
40 000 subs it'd be really nice to get
there i got a live interview tomorrow
at noon and then my first ever panel
show uh
friday at 12 with christopher ruffo nice
uh carolyn b
and corey deangelis is going to be
awesome
gorgeous uh and you can follow me ian
crossland all over the internet social
wise and
my website ian crossland.net you can
pick up some merchandise if you like
including that one guy's favorite
free the code mug shout out to the dude
on the super chatted out about that
thanks for letting me um
specify what i meant by this and um have
some fun and i love you guys
very much that's really cool and i'm
sarah patch lids i push all the buttons
every night at 8 pm
i am at real sour patch lids
on instagram and gab and i am sour patch
lids on
twitter and minds the progressive alpha
coming up over at timcast.com and we
will see you all there bye guys
you